Five four,
three,
two,
one.
Tj.
Yo,
how are you brother?
I'm doing good man.
What is it like now?
What is this?
Uh,
what,
what first of all,
what was it like that night?
If for people don't know,
let me just give you the rundown just
so you don't have to say at co you were
involved in one of the most high
profile flyweight fights ever eat the
bantamweight champion.
It dropped down to flyweight.
You went through this extensive training
routine to get your body down to a
manageable weight where you can cut the
last 10 pounds or so and make one 25 the
fight starts so Hutto
lands a good shot early.
There's a lot,
a lot of action,
and the referee stops the fight.
And I was,
I was shook by it.
Everybody that I was
watching the fight with,
it was like,
what the fuck didn't,
it was almost universal.
Like no one thought it was a good stop.
It's just one of those stoppages
where no one goes as a good stop it,
stop it.
No one.
Everybody was like,
what the fuck?
You jumped off and you're like,
dude,
come on.
Come on man.
It's been rough man.
That's a rough one.
That won't rough one to swallow on,
on multiple reasons,
you know?
Um,
like you say,
he fell,
he landed a good shot.
Um,
the,
everything is being
overshadowed by this shot.
The landing behind my ear,
you know,
um,
I was over off,
balanced it through a right hand.
I came in a little too aggressive.
That's the way I fight,
right?
He pushed me over.
I was off balance.
He threw a kick,
I blocked it and he went to throw a right
hand and I tried to dip out of the way
and it was one of those shots
that hit you behind the head,
like right behind the ear.
Not Illegal,
but I run her feet.
It's completely illegal.
But,
uh,
it was an unfortunate situation.
One of those punches just kind of
takes her feet out from underneath you.
You're 100% there,
but your equilibrium's off,
you know?
And he jumps on me.
Um,
I remember hearing the ref say
Dillashaw show me something.
I told him I'm good.
And I remember talking to him before
the fight in the back and he said,
like,
if I'm telling you that,
make sure you're talking to me,
give me,
show me something,
you know,
but how are you talking?
I said it,
I said I'm good.
I mean,
but in his,
you know,
from,
from his perspective,
how does he expect you to
talk what you're blocking?
Even said too in the back
before the fight too.
Like,
you know,
give me a thumbs up or something if
you're going to choke this or that,
you know.
So,
uh,
to be honest,
I think he was,
I didn't,
I didn't know who he was.
I think he's really
inexperienced watching him.
Raf is well do jumping around as soon
as the commotion and it happened.
He was looking for a
reason to stop it almost.
Um,
but you know,
I can't,
I think it was amped up.
Yeah.
I mean it's a big fight fight for him to,
you know,
for him to get a high profile
fight first time on ESPN plus.
Yes.
Big Deal.
A hundred percent a hundred percent.
So that's the,
I think that's the part that most
bugs me more is that I was there.
Um,
but it was the shot that
hit me behind the head.
Um,
and then obviously the
controversial stoppage.
So it,
it's,
it's a rough one to swallow.
You know,
it's,
it's definitely been bugging me,
but,
uh,
I'm good about keeping my mind off of
things and staying busy and Modi back in
the gym,
um,
doing business things and uh,
trying to stay as busy as possible so I
don't think about it and want to punch a
hole through a wall
every time I walk by one.
Well,
it's such a two
different fight because it was
such an arduous task for you to get
down to flyweight.
I mean,
people are looking,
you look great right now.
Your face is full,
you look healthy.
But God damn,
dude,
I saw you the week of the fight
on television and I was like,
look at his face.
Got tweaker.
Yeah,
you did.
You,
you looked like you were,
uh,
you know,
so who knows?
Said it best.
You look like an ultra marathon runner.
Some guy who runs long distances.
If,
if I would have decided to
lose all the way at the end,
I wouldn't have looked like that.
Right.
But I got my buddy down
to five to 6% body fat,
you know,
so when I start losing
anything towards the end,
it's going to come.
You're going to see it out of my face.
Right.
You know,
and I'm one of those guys that loses
and gains weight out of my face.
You know,
after my fights,
we call myself fat Tyler.
Cause that's my,
my real name is Tyler.
And I go by Tj and Justin buckles
gave me that name back at Alpha male.
Like Tyler.
I'd always get puffy face,
watch my fights in my altar.
He goes fat Tyler,
you know,
I'm going out and eating
and being an asshole.
Um,
Spaghetti.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
but uh,
so when I,
when I decided to,
like if I did it over 12 weeks,
so my body weight was down,
I mean my,
my,
my body fat percentage is down to 5%.
That's crazy.
And so when you lose any
more waterway or anything,
you're going to see it come under your
face because I was doing it for so long
now.
What was it like being that low on
you as far as your body fat goes?
What was your performance like physically?
How'd you feel?
I actually,
so I felt the best I've ever felt
before I walked up before the fight,
and that's another reason why I'm just
so bitter about this thing is because I
didn't get a chance to show
the work that I put in.
I didn't get a chance to show
all the science behind Sam,
Kavita and what he did to my body.
I was stronger for this fight
then it was my last Cody fight.
I walked out two pounds heavier for this
fight than I did my last Cody fight.
What did you walk out too before I
started warming up a wade one 49 watts.
Yes,
and I felt great.
I didn't feel bloated and for nothing.
You went from one 25 to one 49 yeah,
I was a glycogen battery.
I was ready to fucking go.
I couldn't get tired before the fight.
When I was warming up in the back.
I seriously like,
I've never felt better
than this before a fight,
like my mood,
my energy levels like me
hitting mitts with Dwayne,
the back warming up,
I was feeling smooth,
I was feeling good.
I remember even walking out in the cage
and everything felt too good almost too.
I remember looking over
Duane smile on him.
I felt awesome.
Um,
and that's even more of an unfortunate
situation that I didn't get to really
show that,
you know?
Well,
I mean,
hats off to Henry because he's a course
he did catch you and he is one of the
best.
He's a,
I mean there's that kind
of caliber of athlete.
It was what made this fight so special.
You being the bantamweight
champion going down to flyweight.
Yep.
And I think the way you did it is probably
the only way to really do it safely.
For sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess you were safe
because you were only,
you were like,
what,
one 35 ish the day before I made
weight the night before the fight.
Why we are not the night before a Wayans.
So I went to sleep,
uh,
1.3 pounds over and I floated
that actually took a shit
the morning or Wayne's,
which is insane.
That never happens.
Like my body was still working.
Um,
I wanted to make the weight the night
before cause obviously I hadn't made one
25.
I didn't want it to wake up in the morning
and see what my body was going to do
and if it was going to
give me that extra water.
Um,
but I made,
I made weight super easy man.
Like you don't get me wrong.
The 12 weeks was a motherfucker.
It was hard.
It was a lot of work.
But though the actual weight cut was easy.
I had no hiccups,
nothing like would tell me
like what to go to bed at.
He knew what I was going to wake up at.
He tells me the water loading I'm doing,
um,
the amount of electrolytes I'm taking in,
the amount of food I'm eating.
And so he knows exactly what
my buddies and wake up and do.
He's been tracking it for two years now.
That guy,
it sounds brilliant.
I really need to talk to him,
watched videos of him talking about it
and seeing the work and just what a,
what a unique individual he is.
I mean that's why I decided to move back
down to southern California for him.
For him.
Yeah.
And then everything else
kind of came along with it.
My life is wonderful now that
people have got around me.
I'm lucky that I have Duane
Ludwig this willing to try it out,
travel out and train with me out there.
Um,
but I moved down to southern California
because the Sam Kalvia and I came down
to two weeks with him and
started noticing like,
damn,
this guy knows his shit.
You know,
I didn't realize uniquely,
no.
I mean there's a lot of people
out there who know their shit,
but he seems like he's on some new level.
I mean he sent me graphs that I
have on my phone of like the tea,
like he would,
he like to every week
we knew exactly what,
what my body weight wanted to be at.
He was telling me weights that I'd be
at before I would even be there and my
body would just do it,
you know.
Um,
so you didn't need a separate person,
so he's here.
This is what's unusual about this.
Normally if you would hire somebody,
you,
you would hire like a George
Lockhart or something like that,
Mike Dolce and then you would,
you would hire them almost specifically
just for the weight cut and some
nutrition advice.
He's training you physically as well.
He's telling me my low base,
like,
so my long distance running
or my fasted low base.
Yeah.
He does everything.
My strength conditioning,
my nutrition,
he,
they make my meals,
they do all my meal prep.
He's telling me like how much a
low base I need to do per week.
I either morning or night,
he's telling me when I should train.
Um,
it's,
uh,
everything is completely mapped out.
I don't,
there's no guesswork in it.
There's nothing like he's
telling me everything,
like he's listening to my
heart rate when I'm sleeping.
The heart rate variability is,
he's telling me what supplements to take.
Um,
all of it,
you know,
like everything.
I,
I seriously and,
and,
and I,
that's,
that's another reason why it's just so
tough that this fight didn't get to like
really let me prove anything,
not only for myself and who I am,
but the work that this guy put in,
you know,
like I'm going to sit here and brag about
him and tell him about how bad ass he
is.
But then people want to tell me like,
oh,
you're malnourished.
You don't have a chin one 25,
it was a bad cup for you.
They're giving him crap
all over the place.
And,
uh,
I've almost feel just as bad for him as
I do for myself for how much work you
put into it,
how actually how great
I felt before the fight.
And I didn't get a chance to show it.
Like I said,
I walked out at one 49
glycogen battery ready to go.
Um,
I've really never felt better.
I know,
man,
it was insane.
I,
I really couldn't believe like
how my body absorbed everything,
you know?
So what do you walking around like now?
I'm in low 15.
I'm in low fifties right now,
but that's because I'm
trying to be at low 50s.
My body instantly wanted to just store
everything and I got up to like sixties,
low sixties.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
I said,
I started doing,
I started doing some,
uh,
hot yoga and going in and where I
just worked out with Sam yesterday.
I'm going to his house later after this.
And also,
um,
that's kind of the only way my mind can
stay at ease right now with everything
that's been going on as I
need to get back in the gym.
What was that night
like after it was over?
I mean,
going back to your dressing room
and going back to your hotel.
Um,
it was rough,
man.
It was definitely a,
a mother fucker.
It was it.
I was pissed.
You know,
everyone wants to call me like a,
a sore loser.
I've never said I wasn't a sore loser.
I fucking hate losing more than any of,
I mean you,
you show me a champion or a high level
competitor that likes losing and I'll
call you a liar.
You know what I mean?
I think you're 100% correct.
And Jamie and I have talked
about this many times when we're,
you know,
we're talking about the broad
James or Michael Jordan,
those guys were infamous
for being terrible losers.
I hate losing.
Yeah.
I mean,
I just don't think you get to be that
elite of the elite unless you're a fucking
maniac.
Yeah.
I really think that,
I mean,
I think about it constantly.
You know,
I'm one of those OCD guys.
It's,
if I'm not in the gym,
I'm thinking about it.
I'm just thinking about my training and
sometimes I need to distract myself and
also I distract myself with
other businesses or things
I've got going on because
I think about it too much.
Um,
and so,
especially when it's
a controversial thing,
when people are questioning things and
it's going to piss you off even more.
I mean,
I hate losing,
so you're definitely gonna see us.
So at night was rough man.
I mean the ride back to
the hotel and you know,
I didn't want to go out.
I didn't want really want to eat.
I just wanted to hang out with my son,
you know,
like just get me away from fighting
and let me think about my family.
So,
yeah.
um,
where is everything at
right now in terms of,
have you talked to the UFC?
What was their take on everything?
Um,
Dana said it was a quick stoppage.
Yeah.
I mean everyone's been
saying it's quick stop.
Big John McCarthy.
John McCarthy is calling out the raft
saying he thought it was a quick stoppage.
We got,
I talked to any texts on
a couple of nights ago.
The same thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
so everyone,
everyone,
everyone thinks it,
you know,
and uh,
Dana was saying like,
hey,
okay,
we'll figure it out next couple
of days or at least off of edge.
I'm obviously pissed about it.
Just know that nothing,
I want this to happen,
you know.
So,
um,
my manager,
Tiki,
he's been in talks with,
we haven't really heard nothing yet on,
on the decision what's going to happen.
I love Tiki.
He's the best.
He's a great guy.
He's,
he's a great manager because
he's been in the fight game.
He's been around,
he's fine.
He's been here forever,
early UFC days too.
Good dude too.
He's just got such a great personality.
He's just a fun guy to be around.
Yeah.
So He's been,
he's been awesome from a career.
I've only been with
them for a short while,
the time,
but he's been awesome for me.
But,
uh,
he's been in talks with a
hunter and Dana and so we're,
I'm hoping to figure out
something soon because I'm,
I'll fight tomorrow,
you know,
like I'll fight him.
He,
whatever way he wants,
obviously would prefer 20 fives because
I put it in a lot of work and I want to
show that I know what I'm doing.
And it wasn't a fluke or did this was a
fluke that this wasn't something that,
um,
well,
here's the deal.
Even if the fight went longer,
any stopped you and he
legitimately stopped.
Yeah.
Look,
he's Henry.
So who don't mean that that's,
that's a possibility.
This is the game.
100%.
This is what it is.
That's why me so great.
Right.
It is what can happen.
You know what I mean?
Like you go out there like no
matter if you're the huge favorite,
anything can happen.
It just didn't get a chance to happen.
That's what's unfortunate.
I mean,
he really did land.
Some good shots are really
what's coming on strong.
But he came out ready.
He was,
yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
And so were you,
which is why that fight
was so interesting.
He had some shit to prove.
He was there to save
the flyweight division.
Yeah.
And look,
he did it.
No one,
I mean,
until I had the balls
enough to drop down in 2025,
there really wasn't any
hype on a flyweight fight.
Um,
the net that was,
and now there still is
and he wants to save that.
He wants talk about saving
the flyweight division.
Then let's do it.
Well,
I think he wants to go up course
and he's then he can be champ champ.
And I understand that when there was
no champ champ or Connor came wrong,
Conor really changed the
game with so many ways.
But I mean,
one of the ways he changed the game
was calling himself champ champ.
Now everybody is chat,
chat,
you know Ryan baders champ champ.
You help me.
No,
I mean Amanda Nunez is champion.
It's a way to market yourself and get
your name out there and it is a really big
deal.
You know I'm at the term champ champ.
Oh yeah.
It's like that is a
fucking Conor McGregor.
That's a Conor McGregor term.
He's got some,
uh,
he's got some gold behind his touch.
Anything he touches turns into gold.
I not lucky charm.
He's a character.
He is who he is.
And I understand that.
I mean,
I'll fight Henry scooter whatever way
he wants to fight cause I have no,
I can't,
I can't dictate where it goes because
I just said what had just happened,
you know,
it seems like the correct way to do it
would be at 25 because if you guys fought
at 35,
um,
it's,
you know,
it's a different ball
of wax and it percent,
I just think given the circumstances and
the fact that you did make the weight
fairly not easy,
I wouldn't never say easy.
I would say easy.
I mean,
like I said,
it's a lot of work,
but dude,
I can't believe how actually easy it was.
Um,
I mean it was like going through the
graphs that Sam showed me and it was
remarkable.
I got stronger,
I was putting up more weight.
So the last week before I left,
before my fight,
I was snatching and cleaning a more
weight than my last Cody fight.
And I was lighter.
So my power ratio was insane.
It almost is unheard of,
but I think it's because of how strict
the had to be for those 12 weeks is maybe
why I'm like what was your diet like?
Like what do you eat in and out of key?
I could,
you can't be in Ketosis obviously
cause I trained too hard.
Right.
But um,
no grains,
you know,
if I'm eating carbs,
simple carbs,
things like that,
like fruits,
fruits,
vegetables,
sweet potatoes,
things like that.
And you're weighing everything out.
They do all that.
I,
I'm,
I'm not doing it personally myself.
Sam,
his family do it.
Um,
the training lab,
they every meal,
every snack.
So I meet him three meals a day.
I'm actually pretty good calories too.
I mean three meals a day,
two snacks a day on.
But it's also about when I stopped
beating my intermittent fasting,
me doing my low base warm
while I'm fasting to get my
body to be burned in 100%
fats.
And what you said doing your low base.
What do you mean by my like long distance.
So low cardio,
slow movements along.
So it's not hard.
It's something I want to keep my heart
rate at a certain variable depending on
what my vo two Max is,
what my Rmr is.
There's this crossover where your body
starts burning carbs or starts burning
fats.
If you're sprinting,
you're going hard and hard and hard.
Your body is going to start burning
carbs cause it needs to burn carbs to go
that hard.
But when you're at a certain
level like so for instance,
when I started camp,
my crossover was at one 45 so I need
to keep my heart rate under one 45 for
maybe four to five minutes.
There may be,
now I'm getting closer.
I need to lose more weight
and need to go an hour.
So one 45 is a,
is that 80% no,
70% of your heart rate must be a,
everyone's different.
It depends on your vo two is,
um,
I don't remember what mine was exactly
what percentage wise at one 45 is a sweet
spot where you're burning
fat at the beginning of camp.
But towards the end of the camp,
I can go to like one 55
because I got in better shape.
Um,
my,
I,
I was just in better shape as a better
machine that where I could go harder and
still be in a fat burning substrate.
And then he would dictate if I need
you to do 40 minutes in a minute,
maybe an hour at night,
and depending on how we wanted my body
to react and then he's also spiking and
take away my insulin levels to get my,
because I don't want to be
in Ketosis always right?
Cause my body will crash,
but I need to be in it to get my body
weight down without losing weight
unhealthy.
If I would have waited to the
last two weeks of crash my weight,
I would have been dehydrated.
But all the way up until wanes,
my body was over 60,
60% hydrated.
Most of the camp I was 66% hydrated.
Um,
and that's because you don't only get
hydrated from the water you drink,
you're hydrated from the supplements
you're going to take and the foods you're
taking in inside yourselves.
So when you say you're
getting into Ketosis,
are you doing it 100% through diet or
you take an exhaustion is ketones or
you're doing anything else?
Just Diet and the way I work out diet,
the way you work out and then the
intermittent fasting is a 16 hour window.
You using?
We switch it up.
Um,
when I was getting closer to fight.
Yeah.
Um,
but when I was further out maybe like,
you know,
14 hours,
things like that and I wasn't,
I didn't,
I didn't have to intermittent
fast the whole camp,
you know,
just after a certain point I need to get
my buddy Wayne even lower than it was
that there's this,
this trend that we were following to
continue to get my body weight down.
And he would,
um,
implement certain things to,
to force it that direction.
Well,
it's just,
I've never seen,
I mean,
I know some pretty well
documented training routines
and diet routines and some
guys have really gotten into
the weeds with this stuff,
but I don't think I've
ever seen it like you man.
Um,
I was always into training
and doing everything as,
as well as I can and,
and find every
angle I could possibly be
to be the best athlete.
That's my competitive edge.
Um,
and then when I met Sam,
I knew that was my next level and I
didn't realize that it had low test.
And before I met Sam,
until he tested my levels and did
my hair analysis and all that stuff,
I didn't realize what was
going on with my body.
I just trained hard and I
thought I was training smart.
Then I met Sam.
It took it to a whole nother level.
Well,
the training hard,
sometimes the problem is your body just
never really gets a chance to catch up.
They're really gets a chance to recover.
And there's a lot of really good fighters
that are doing that to themselves
because they're just,
you know,
especially wrestlers,
they have that mentality
just to just fucking go.
They don't care if they're miserable,
they're mentally tough,
they keep pushing,
and your body just is always
behind the eight ball.
You never really get a chance to recover.
I was red line in my body.
Yeah,
I was,
I was not eating right and I was
working out as hard as I possibly could,
pound in the caffeine,
uh,
and my body was just telling me,
no,
you know,
my,
my top men's testosterone
was crashed and like,
to see where it's at now is amazing.
You know,
what did he do to boost it back up?
My Diet,
my segmentation,
which all my supplements are
food based for the most part.
I mean,
there'll be supplements,
but they're Aminos in all
whole food banks days,
magnesium,
Zincs,
a trip to fans.
And one of the things
glycine is tyrosines oh,
Krill oil.
Know all different ways in
different times of taking,
depending on what I'm doing,
I'm the certain kind of create teams.
I'm taking,
my proteins are all,
uh,
organic.
Um,
he's uh,
this company or gain that's,
I,
I take a lot of their stuff,
you know,
there,
there everything's tested or organic.
Um,
so everything I'm doing is all whole,
whole food based supplements.
And then the way I'm training as well too,
like,
so he's listened to my heart
rate variability when I sleep.
What do you,
what are you wearing to,
uh,
wear a heart rate monitor made by Suunto.
Okay.
But yeah,
it's not so much the heart
and monitor that does it.
It's his algorithm that does it.
So every morning I wake up,
my phone's connected to my watch.
I say my,
my heart rate on a phone,
a phone,
just a apple phone.
But it's just the APP is
a first be I think it is.
But your watch,
it's connected to your,
do you have a swatch watch and
it connects traverse Alphas?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
mine's a,
yeah,
something like that.
But it connects to your phone
through Bluetooth and then,
um,
and so you're wearing the
monitor with the watch.
The watch is just on the nightstand,
right.
I sleep with the Monitor on and it
will track me all the to my sleep.
I mean you may only want like,
you know when you get into that rem
sleep and it's like three hours and it'll
automatically,
I wake up,
I sync it to my phone,
it sends it to his program and then he's
got an algorithm and to tell me like
what percentage recovery I am,
you know,
cause this is his own proprietary
program that he's developed himself.
Yeah.
Jesus is for us taking him.
I mean do this guy is a genius man.
I'm telling you like me hanging out
with him for two years and I'm finally
getting it all somewhat down.
You know,
I've learned so much from it.
I mean I've learned more from him in the
last two years than I've ever learned
to school.
And I was a kinesiology major.
I was cleaning clinical exercise science.
I was going to be a physician's assistant.
I was always into the body,
but just going and working out with him
and his garage,
his little tiny,
you know,
garage that it looks like you'd never
think world champions train there every,
you know,
like the,
and p goes,
the one arch Liletta is myself,
cub,
Swanson,
like all these bad guys go in and train
and there's just some little garage.
But I've learned more from him in that
garage than I've ever learned through any
of my schools and become wanting
to become a physician's assistant.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
what did you think of the Pico fight?
Oh man,
it's so unfortunate.
Crazier.
He's just,
he's such a killer that he
wants to knock everyone out.
Not only does he want to be
the best fighter in the world,
but he wants to be the most
entertaining fighters in the world.
So he's looking to punish you because
he's got so many weapons that he doesn't
use.
He's so good,
man.
Um,
but he lives by the sword and he
dies by the sword kind of thing.
You know,
he wants to be that,
that knock you out entertaining fight or
he wants to be able to show a highlight
reel first round knockouts,
you know,
um,
which is great.
Yeah.
But you always have to understand that
you are just like the guy right in front
of you and that one shot,
especially in MMA,
one shot can turn it all around.
And it did.
It was one of the most shocking knock
out something I've ever seen because it
looked like he looked fucking phenomenal.
He came out there and we knew that he
had been trading with you for this fight
who was fucking shredded.
He looked like a world beater,
you know,
went out their land in that clean up
or caught and then God just way carried
away.
Yup.
And it's unfortunate because you think
I'm in shape and I do crazy things.
This guy is putting me to
shame like Sam's garage,
but he's able to do on the bike and just
as workout regimen and like just how
competitive he is.
Man.
He's a,
he's a world beater.
He could be by far will champion.
You know,
there's some things that he's in,
he's so young,
so there's some things we
need to get to figure out.
Everyone takes losses and uh,
help them.
One of these is going to just spark him
to realize how good he is everywhere,
you know?
And uh,
yeah.
It's just an unfortunate situation.
MMA.
Yeah.
I mean guys have bounced back from
knockouts and become world champions
unquestionably.
It's just,
he's got to make sure he
doesn't have too many of those,
you know,
and,
and make sure we fight smart.
Agreed uses,
use that goddamn wrestling too.
It's insane risks.
I mean,
he's so good as a wrestler and
when he gets that guy hurt,
he's collar tie there.
They're grabbing each other by
the neck and just swinging shots.
You're,
you're flipping a coin and
you're rolling the dice.
He got six fights or something like that.
Yeah.
I mean it's one of those
inexperience things and he's only 22.
Yeah.
I mean that's the other thing.
And you realize like when he dropped him,
he could have jumped on him.
He could have swarmed
him like Henry did to me.
You know,
like jump on him and swarm
them and look for that finish.
But um,
I think the inexperience kind of makes
him realize like they may be he's
invincible and just,
I don't know man.
There's,
there's things that you kind of figure
out when you've been out in the cage
longer and longer and you've
been around the creek,
you understand there's
ways to finish a fight or,
or how to,
how to just be a smart fighter that
he'll figure out what was the whole
experience like being on this
ESPN card because it's a,
that was a historic moment,
much like,
like the Cain Velasquez
vs junior dos Santos,
which also stopped the same way
and that was that controversial.
That was not comfortable punch though.
The Punch that landed
was also behind the ear.
Same Punch.
You know,
like it's one of those things that you,
it just takes your feet out from,
if you've ever fought or
if you've ever been in,
got hit in the back of the head,
weird.
Your feet go out from underneath you,
but you're there,
you're a hundred percent
aware of what's going on.
But your balance isn't there,
then you have another
grown man on top of you.
You know,
so of course things are gonna happen.
But uh,
with the ESPN it was really cool.
The whole lead up to it.
They film,
they came to film my late,
they were around a lot.
They did a lot of exposure.
They,
um,
the stuff they put out was really cool.
And then just seeing like our commercial
for a fight on national football,
on ESPN or for the call it,
you know,
because college was going on and then
you'd see the nationals is going on and
you'd see me in re like three
different commercials and ESPN.
I thought that was pretty cool.
No,
it was amazing.
You know,
I mean,
it really,
it's cool to see,
it's cool to see that ESPN is embracing
the sport and then it's getting into it.
And you know,
there was a lot of hype
behind this and you know,
I got ESPN plus I wasn't,
yeah,
no.
I mean I'm not a sports fan.
I don't watch sport.
I don't even know what's happening.
Like what people like,
what are you doing for the Superbowl?
I'm like,
when's that?
That's exactly what I did.
I don't have time for it,
man.
Um,
I'm a,
I'm a Raiders fan,
but I don't have time to really watch,
you know.
Right.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean it's just,
when you think of sports,
you think ESPN.
Yeah.
You really do.
I mean,
it's another level of
acceptance in the sports world.
The only thing that kind of bumped me out,
and I should probably clarify this because
I talked about this on the podcast,
was the hardy fight.
And not,
not even because I don't think the guy
should be fighting or not even because I
think I,
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't really know what he
did in terms of his past.
I know there's a lot of,
there's a lot of shit,
right?
I mean,
he was in trouble for something.
There was an appeal and
he got off of it somehow.
I don't know,
but I'm only talking about it
from a fighting perspective.
You're watching the highest level fights.
You're watching the co main event.
He's just not ready for a co main event.
Like technically no,
no way.
Yeah.
Just see what he rushed out.
He gassed out,
he burned himself out,
Crowder recovered and it just,
it's not the way it should
be is you should have the
early fights are people who
are learning the sport.
And then when you get to
the last couple of fights,
the cove,
Maine and the main,
you're supposed to be seeing
assassins like you and Henry.
So Huda,
that's what you're supposed to be seeing.
And it just,
yeah.
Crazy thing about our sport is,
is a lot of entertainment
behind it as well too.
So if you're hyped up,
you get pushed up the ladder,
maybe you get title fight
sooner than you should.
And that's crazy because
now we're on ESPN,
now we're like,
we're an official,
I mean we've been an official sport,
but yeah,
it should be more on the level like
you're talking about of the actual skill
level and how you're ranked.
I mean,
cowboy Serone and the Alex kid should
have been the a hundred percent main
event.
100% I was stunned that it wasn't.
They imagine they were on real,
they were on ESPN though.
They wanted to kind of hype up and plus,
you know,
sense.
That makes sense for that
reason.
Yeah.
But there's another fight they
could have put in place of that.
I mean there's 100% and the it,
Ken,
this is not a knock on Crowder or hardy.
There are guys out there doing it.
They're,
they're trying,
they did their job.
They did their job.
They're fighting.
The ending was super unfortunate.
Yeah.
Again,
you don't know whether or
not he did it on purpose,
whether he had a mental,
you're getting punched in the face
and that stuff happens so fast.
Chaos.
I mean especially because he is so new,
right?
Yes.
He hasn't been fighting forever.
Like that stuff just happens.
Like,
oh,
I got them hurt,
you know,
don't like,
there's things like I've
even done in practices.
Oh Shit Dude,
I'm so,
I'm in practice and I did something.
I'm like,
Oh man,
that was stupid.
Like it happens in a fight.
I'm losing a point.
Like I'm so sorry.
You know,
like it's just bums me out that
this rush to commercialization,
that this,
this rush to trying to
get the most eyes on it.
The people that are watching it.
If you watch something where there's
two guys who really aren't ready for Co
main event,
but you're seeing sloppiness and guys
getting out of gas real quick and you see
all the things that you're supposed to
learn early in your career so that by the
time you get to a co main event,
you know you're a fucking assassin,
you're,
you're locked down and a
hundred percent professional.
You're a real elite pro fighter.
That's what I want to see
when I'm watching ESPN.
Yeah,
that's what I want to see you.
I want to see the best of the best.
You know,
I want to see world class
fighters fighting with
precision and power and speed
and knowing how to pace themselves guys
or the experience they've been there
before.
They know how to recover from things.
They get cracked.
They know how to lay back.
They know how to hold on.
They know how to do what they need to
do in order to win or fight their best
instead of like just like you're seeing
things and so many people are seeing
this at this point and I feel like
we're getting fans and all that are more
knowledgeable like yourself and,
and,
and people are seeing this
sport and understanding
technique now to where before
maybe it didn't matter,
you didn't know what bad technique is now,
you know,
but we get more knowledgeable fans to
where they are going to start realizing
it.
Like what was that like?
Right.
The last thing you want to see
is two heavyweights gassed out.
Yes.
That is the fucking worst.
Yeah.
Do you remember when,
um,
what was it Ben Rothwell?
Was it Mark Hunt?
I think it was Ben Roswell
and Mark Hunt fought in,
I want to say it so it's two
guys when it might be wrong.
See if that's in Denver.
They made him fight at altitude.
I remember the fight in Denver.
I don't know if it was them either,
but yeah,
it was fucking ridiculous.
Cause they're there at altitude and
there's so goddamn tired and like fucking,
and the UFC is like,
we're never going to do a heavyweight
fight again ever at altitude.
It wasn't,
yeah,
it was been Rothbaum Mark Hunt,
but then they wound up
doing Cain Velasquez and um,
uh,
are there very doom for
IBC where Mexico City,
which is even higher,
it's 2000 feet above Denver.
Dune was smart,
went up there early,
we looked like a killer out there,
you know.
Um,
and,
and I think from what
I remember that came,
went out there two weeks before the fight,
which actually makes it worse for you.
It'd be better off if you went
up there three days before
the fight,
cause your body still in shock,
right?
Rather than going up there in two
weeks and now your body's screwed.
You know,
you need to be there.
If you're going to be there early,
go six weeks or more,
don't,
don't go less.
If you're gonna go less come through a
couple of days because your body is still
in shock and you see how a fight like
that can literally change the course of a
fighter's career.
Yes.
I mean it changed Keynes
career in many ways.
You know,
one,
one loss like that to a
guy like Fabricio over.
Do you know,
um,
he's fighting real,
real soon.
Side freelance,
right?
Francis and Ghana help.
He's healthy.
He has to.
I hope so.
God dammit.
Yeah.
I mean if he's not,
he's in trouble cause man,
he could be the best heavyweight.
I mean,
I think he was the best heavyweight,
just unfortunate situations where
he didn't get to to prove that.
I mean he's one of the,
well I think his thing was that his
body just couldn't deal with his mind.
Like his mind is so strong and his,
his will and his work ethic is so powerful
and that Goddamn camp of killers off
the true San Jose Aka is just a Sasson
central and just the years of wrestling.
Yeah,
I mean wrestling.
Yup.
Hurt me more than anything.
Really.
Anything for that I still do today.
Even if I get hurt today.
It's from wrestling practice.
It's wrestling is the
hardest thing on my body.
Um,
your neck,
your back,
your shoulders,
it,
I mean it's,
it's rough,
you know,
same Kalvia son right now.
[inaudible] he's been on the couch for
the last four months and it was from
wrestling here.
His back eat a bulging disc
in his back or her knee disc.
I'm from wrestling and he's 16
years old and she was just curls.
That's a rough one.
When you're that young
and you hurt your back.
Yeah man.
Wow.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's a part of his back.
It's lower.
Yeah.
Lower back.
What's he got them doing for it?
I would always assume a guy like that
and was exactly what to do to try to heal
something like,
yeah.
So He's been doing,
oh,
so we've been a,
he's had to,
we,
they tried doing everything naturally,
but he's had to go and get
a couple of epidurals now.
Um,
the kind of the shrink to swelling.
So the um,
uh,
obviously it's not,
so it's pushing on a nerve and so it's
messing with the static nerve and it's
hard for him to walk.
He was having a crawl
around the house like a dog.
Like she's laid on the couch forever
and now he's starting to walk.
Um,
but Sandy's got 'em out in the garage
doing pull ups cause that's the only thing
he can do because it's a decompression,
you know,
he's like well hold onto the bar at least
and and get some pull ups in and start
to strengthen his back so that it holds
his spine kind of where it needs to be.
Cause when he's losing insane
amounts of muscle mass.
I mean this kid was 16
years old looking good,
working out with his dad in
the garage and then gets hurt.
Now it looks like a different person.
I feel bad for him
being a 16 year old kid,
you know.
Well I,
I definitely feel bad that it looks bad,
but I really feel bad that he's
got that kind of an injury at 16.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's an injury.
See which guys in their
twenties and thirties,
and you,
you know,
you realize it's a
lifetime of beating on it.
That when you get to that,
when you're 16,
that's not good.
I dealt with it in my neck,
um,
and college and then also early in my
fighting career and it messes with you.
I had to get a epidural shot in my
neck throughout the front bulging disk.
Uh,
yeah,
it was pushing on a nerve and I
lost like 70% of the in my left.
The harm
it,
you know,
it's rough man.
Yeah.
I was on my way,
the exact same thing.
I was getting numbness in the
hands and the ulnar nerve,
which goes from like your pinky down
through your elbows getting pain in my
elbow.
But I got real lucky that
I found a good doctor,
got some spinal decompression
and Regena keen.
Oh.
And really fixed it up me.
Yeah.
It's that blood spinning procedure
that heat up your blood and then they,
um,
they,
they run it through a centrifuge and
they pull this yellow serum out of it.
There was a week.
Is that your plasma right?
Yeah,
we detailed it what it is.
We showed a thing from the website
that shows the stuff they add to it,
but it was pretty remarkable and a lot
of people with back injuries are finding
real,
real powerful relief for that because
not only does it reduce the inflammation
but it actually really
speeds up your healing.
Um,
but for me,
um,
the spinal decompression was
like one of the best things ever.
It's just that harness that you strap
on your neck and hang from the door.
I have fucking things amaze that click,
click,
click done.
That one I have the one that it's,
it's not as nice as that one.
My music where it like you pump it up,
it's like,
well that'll go into neckbrace.
You put it on like hardly does anything
and then you pump it up with air,
stretches your neck out,
try to get taller.
Well you definitely get
shorter as you get older.
That's true.
And that's what it is.
I mean,
Eddie Bravo gained an inch.
He's a,
he's five,
nine now because he had a disc replaced.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
all the years of Jujitsu and weightlifting
and wrestling and everything is
getting squashed.
Him folding himself in half all the time,
all his lower back was destroyed,
destroyed.
And also he's not the guy to
guy who balances everything out.
Like he just Kinda does it and smokes
weed because he eats a burrito.
Tell.
Yeah.
So his lower back was just fuck the army,
but it was essentially bone on bone
and we're just constant state of
inflammation.
He was always in pain.
Like he'd be standing up,
like if we were somewhere,
like say if we went to a bar and it had
a couple of drinks or something like
that,
he'd be standing up.
He'd be in pain just
standing for too long.
And there's a worldclass Jujitsu practice.
Yeah.
So he got his disc replaced
and gained an inch.
They put a,
well,
I mean he had nothing.
And then all of sudden
he's got an inch of disc.
Wow.
And it's a titanium,
uh,
articulating disk.
So it actually moves around.
It's not fused.
Okay.
So it's in the old days,
they would take your,
your to you,
these,
you know,
the vertebrae and lock them
together and screw them in place.
And it's a nightmare because it puts an
artificial load on the upper disc above
it and the lower disc is now
there's this unusual leverage there,
but instead of that,
now they use a desk and actual disc,
they put it in place and it lasts a long
ass fucking time and it moves around
like you and he doesn't
have any pain anymore.
And guys are back to Roland and I know a,
you know,
some real,
Chris Weidman actually just got
a disc replaced in his neck.
I saw that as well now.
But Caina his fused.
Right.
Cause he had back problems
and his was his fused.
He's got a bunch of
shit going on his back.
He's had multiple back surgeries.
I don't know the exact extent of all
the different surgeries that he got,
but he's definitely got a lot
of stuff going on in his bag.
Yeah.
Interesting.
You seem a bit,
becomes back healthy and looks good.
Look man.
Um,
a skill for skill,
ability for ability.
I think he,
if he's not the best of all time,
it's him and Fader,
you know,
and then you always have to
mention Verdomme cause even
though Steve Bay knocked
for do mountain,
the first round for doom is submitted,
the best of the best submitted Minataro
he submitted fade or he submitted Kaine.
I mean what the fuck?
I mean that that guy,
is it just for doing
it for dooms record it,
if you just look at who he's fine,
he's fine.
He's the best.
Yeah.
I in my opinion,
and for how long he's been around,
but it's like,
but when did he beat those guys?
Like when did he beat those guys?
Did he beat those?
Like when you beat fade or fade or was
as close to his prime as you can get
when,
you know,
like it's hard to say.
Like the Brett Rogers fight,
a lot of people were saying he wasn't
as focused for the Brett Rogers Swipe,
but he's still knocked
him out with one punch.
Remember that crazy fucking chaos.
Anytime you gotta be ready
for Fado or Warren cash.
Yeah.
But Verdomme handled him,
you know,
on the ground and submitted them.
I would have loved to seen what
it was like in pride if you,
he could fight him when fader was at his
peak click back when he beat Minataro.
Yeah.
But for doom,
you know,
he's,
he's overlooked.
And that argument of WHO's the best and
in terms of like accomplishments as a
UFC fighter,
well it's steep a cause Steve has the
only guy to defend the title four times
and it really kind of bums me out that
he's out of the conversation right now.
You don't hear about a Steve Bay fight
and he's like a to which I feel like he
should get more attention for
this and he's just a normal guy.
Like he has a full time job where as a
firefighter like I feel like more people
should resonate with them because of that.
Yeah.
But they don't,
I don't,
he's a fucking great guy.
It's kind of be an asshole
to get attention these days.
I don't know.
I mean,
I feel like if he had
beaten DC and you know,
I mean beat Francis,
that was a big fight because Francis came
into that fight with a lot of hype and
Overeem,
knock out Steve Bay,
fall like a fucking champion,
have really fought like a champion.
Smart.
And he showed Francis and look,
Francis fought after that.
He was not the same thing.
No.
When he fought after then
he fight Derrick Lewis.
You could see he was
still throwing anything.
He was still fucked up from that last
fight and he admitted it to his credit,
you know,
and he bounced back with the Curtis
blades fight and look fantastic in that
form.
Cause blades is the awesome wrestler.
Exactly.
A clay blades.
Blades is a very athletic wrestler.
He's huge and he's big.
He's fast,
he's powerful and you know,
and that's twice.
Francis has beaten them twice.
He stopped them.
That was his first UFC fight.
So,
um,
he stopped him then and he
stopped him in this one as well.
So coming into this fight with Kane,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of questions.
We haven't seen Kane in two years,
right?
It's been about two years.
Yeah.
It may mean longer,
let's say,
when was the last time
Cain Velasquez fought time?
Yeah.
I think you might be right.
If he might be three years.
It's been a while.
I know,
but when,
when he was at the top of the food chain,
when Kane was at the top,
he would put a fucking
storm on these people.
That was just like a hundred
year storm would never end.
It's like,
how was this guy have this kind of
insurance CBRE doing to do with that?
Him To hemo and Mexico City was crazy.
I thought it'd be the other way around.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
And just see Cain tired.
Yeah.
So here we go.
2016 yeah.
July 9th.
So two and a half years.
Yeah.
Almost.
And that was Travis Brown,
which is just a phenomenal beating.
Um,
and that was a UFC 200 yeah.
And they did the junior dos
Santos won before that was a year,
you know,
so he's like,
like he's been active.
Well he had children's
2013 look at those gaps.
Yup.
Dang.
Two year gaps.
Yup.
One year,
two year.
Again.
That's rough man.
It is.
It is rough.
Especially when this is your
job and how you get paid.
Fuck yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
Lucky's a heavyweight and they
get taken care of a little more.
But yeah,
it's,
yeah,
I mean it's just,
I wonder how,
how much you can fix all that
stuff that's going on in the spine.
You know what I mean?
It's one thing if a guy gets a knee,
you know he's got a ACL
or something like that,
you know that you can come back
from that and that's 100% possible.
But back stuff is weird.
Once it seems like once
things start going,
it's like you like a car.
You know,
once a ball joint blows out and the
axle starts grinding and you're like,
God,
Jesus,
it's like a bunch of
shits going to go wrong.
Something that that's like your core.
Yeah,
but at his best man,
he was fucking terrifying.
Yeah.
Cause it's just,
I'd never saw it heavyweight with
that kind of endurance ma'am.
Ever being so scared to Cain Velasquez.
And I was like,
I think I talked about this last time in
your podcast when I was a kid wrestling
in college cause I was like this tiny
ass little white boy wrestler and Kate
would walk around with justice singlet
straps on and shorts and he had brown
[inaudible] brown pride
tattooed across his chest.
He's just huge heavyweight
wrestling d one phrase you.
I was just like so scared of that guy.
Like Damn,
look at that guy man.
Just walk around like wonder.
Probably rip my head off.
Has Brown pride tattooed on his chest.
Just wearing justice Singlish drafts.
Just huge.
It's funny,
I remember him forever,
man.
Well you know him and DC,
having that kind of a relationship is
such an unique situation for the two
fighters that they have.
You know,
another elite guy that's their size and
they just smashed each other left and
right and work with each other.
That's what I tried to
create wherever I go.
Um,
and that's what we're doing
in southern California.
I know one or two let,
uh,
Aaron Picos a cub,
Swanson is,
we're trying to build a room of
the smaller guys that we can,
but we don't want to kill each other.
Right.
And that's something that I've
always had to control myself.
I've always gone really hard and
something I've had to learn to control.
Um,
but having that room full of killer so
that when we go to wrestling practice,
like you don't know if you're
going to have a good practice,
you might be getting beat up on that
day when you go home and bell pissed off
like,
Shit,
I had a bad practice,
I got taken down with this.
But that's what makes you
better for the next practice.
If you just go to practice and
beat up on everyone every day,
you're never going to know
what you need to change,
what you need to get better at.
So I think that's why,
uh,
Kanan and DC have gotten so good so
quick at MMA that each other to build off
of,
you know,
if you can survive it.
Yeah.
If you survive it.
And you know,
like the knock on Aka,
some people said they trained too
hard cause they're always injured.
But look at the amount of
champions they produced.
Yes.
Look at the amount of fucking
killers that had come out of there.
Luke Rockhold,
DC,
Kane,
Khabib.
I mean,
get the fuck Outta here.
That places a den of assassins,
you can survive it.
Right.
That's perfect.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean that's the only way man.
I mean,
look,
it's not good to spar full clip like old
school lions den days where they used
to beat the shit out of
it or the military days.
I mean,
nobody knew a thing back then.
They didn't know the consequences.
They didn't know what it's like.
It was speaking of which,
um,
there's an article in the New York Times
today that I was reading on a guy that
we knew Jason Harris done and
it just talks about his CTE.
And how bad it was.
And um,
you know,
Jason is a guy who founded this clothing
company that we know called cu you and
um,
he had been on the podcast before a new,
it's just,
yeah,
it's crazy cause something you never
would have guessed how bad it was either
his guy because every time
I seen him he was happy.
He's awesome.
People don't know the story.
He committed suicide
about a year ago or so.
Yeah.
And um,
no one,
no one outside of it.
So I'd comment it was a judge,
just a giant crazy blow and um,
you know,
I was uh,
texting back and forth with
one of his friends and uh,
you know,
essentially said he had a broken brain.
Man didn't make sense because
when your brain is broken,
it's like having a broken phone.
It's like having a broken anything.
It's just broken.
It's not working.
Right.
It's irrational.
It doesn't make sense.
I couldn't imagine the thoughts I had
been going through his head to have that
happen because like I was texting
him two weeks before it happened,
like talking about going on a hunt with
him and doing this and that and he's
like talking about how
great the business is doing.
Like you think he's
living the American dream,
like awesome.
You know,
so it's tough man.
I couldn't even,
I couldn't even put myself like
to have that kind of torture when,
you know,
he was friends with Donald Junior
and Donald Trump jr and you know,
they hunted together and he was
talking to him just a few hours before.
Like everything was fine.
Yeah.
You know,
they were going back and
forth with each other.
Everybody was blown away.
Like what happened?
Like how would,
how could this possibly happen?
Yeah.
But you know,
scary thing,
more reason for us to be smart as
we possibly can with our training.
Yes.
100%.
That's what I was going to get into this,
um,
the,
that there is a way to train hard but
save your body from especially critical
damage,
like brain damage.
There is a way to do that and Dwayne
has been a savior to me because of that.
You know,
Dwayne with his experience of fighting
and being through the gyms and him
probably going to hard himself,
we've learned a lot of hard drilling and,
and live drilling through him that has
probably going to prolong my career and
hopefully my life and,
and not going as hard and just
spark because like before,
before Dwayne,
when I was at huff melt,
we sparred like three,
four times a week.
We just went,
you know,
that's what we did.
We were wrestlers and that's
how we knew how to get better.
It was just go and then he came in and
start teaching us like how to drill and
how to,
to really get better and your
reaction times everything with,
with fighting,
without having to beat
yourself up so much.
My injuries were less,
I wasn't getting injured as much.
Um,
and I actually got a lot better too.
Yeah.
I think sparring is critical.
Thinking it is important,
but I think maybe as critical
or maybe more is drilling,
and this is with all martial arts,
including Jujitsu and Jujitsu.
It's,
you know,
you do Jujitsu,
it's fun.
So everybody wants to just slap hands,
punched out goals and start rolling.
Yes.
It's fun.
It's fun to,
it's like a fun game you're doing.
It's a good release.
Yeah.
But the best way to get better
at it is to constantly drill.
And then you develop these pathways
that are just ingrained in your
subconscious.
And so when you're in
that half guard position,
you immediately go for that under hook.
You immediately,
you know the path,
you know where to go instead of ad
libbing and thinking while you're in the
middle of a role.
And when you see guys that come
from camps where they don't drill,
the only do like one technique
at the beginning of the class,
you'll notice a technical deficiency as
opposed to like someone who comes from
Hixson school or someone who comes from
a school that's very technical or you
know,
the Mendez brothers or something.
You know,
it's just,
it's so important to look at this,
look at the sport,
whether it's MMA or kickboxing
or Jujitsu or whatever it is.
But to look at it like a,
like a puzzle,
like you're trying to figure out what's
the best way to solve this and you know,
what Dwayne has done for you.
It's been pretty remarkable as far as
like giving you footwork skills and tools
to move around and angles.
And I,
you know,
I've watched you guys drill,
drill and train together and
it's really amazing stuff.
Yeah.
Stuff that we think is simple and then
we go and teach it to the gym and then
there's like,
wait,
what can you guys do
that like 10 more times?
We need to see that again.
It's like,
oh,
all right.
So we've just been doing like the full
work I've created with Dwayne that he
wasn't a footwork guy and when he fought
he was trained NATO's and then like
he's the one that's creating all these
angles with me and now we've created a
whole new style.
It's so funny that he saw that
kind of while he was fighting.
And then after he was fighting,
he's implementing and on new fighters
and didn't do it himself and he laughs
about it.
Yeah.
He,
he wishes he probably would have
had someone like himself coach.
I'm obviously fucking for sure.
Yeah,
everybody does.
Yeah.
He's a fucking wizard man.
He is because he doesn't stop
thinking about it either to,
he's like a Sam Kalvia for strike.
I'm,
I'm telling you like I have odd,
the best coaches in the world around me.
Like he's like same
Kalvia of striking in MMA.
Um,
and I'm trying to convince him to come
to southern California and start a
professional fight team so that we can
help recreate what we do for everyone.
Because you're going to
get them to move out here.
Yeah.
The labs Colorado.
But he does.
He does.
But he also loves being the
best coach in the world anyhow.
So I'm hoping that I can
convince him enough that he,
he'll do that.
You know,
close.
You think you are the convincing them.
I think I'm close to La.
I know you're,
listen brother,
I know you want to come to California.
I've never anybody with his detailed,
um,
uh,
an instruction manual,
like the way he breaks down his
system no matter what striking.
I mean it's really remarkable.
Even when he comes into
here to talk to you,
he'll have a system that you need to
tell him what he wants to talk about,
what he wants to do.
Like the guy doesn't stop thinking he is,
he's on top of his stuff.
He's OCD in a good way.
Yeah.
And the best way in the best way.
Absolutely.
Well it's like you were saying
about being competitive.
I mean,
I think it's you,
the idea that you're going to be this
balance chilled out person and still be a
fucking world smashing.
Good luck with that.
I'm the farthest thing
from relaxed and chill,
you know,
I try to now,
but,
but when you're training
and when you look,
there's a mindset that's required to
beat the best guys and it's not the same
mindset that's required
to get good to get,
you could get good and be a chilled out,
relaxed person.
Like say you want to be
a black belt in Jujitsu,
that's totally possible.
You can be really good.
People can go,
Hey,
look at Mike Mann.
Mike has got great triangle.
Watch them roll.
Wow,
he's really good.
But if Mike wants to be the
motherfucker have motherfuckers,
you better be crazy.
You know,
you better be God damn crazy.
You better be like Mike
Tyson when he was young.
Yup.
Be those Michael Jordan's
you're talking about,
they're always thinking about it.
[inaudible] Jones Jr yes.
All of those guys.
You gotta be a fucking crazy person.
Absolutely.
Everyone's Roy Jones Jr
played a professional
basketball game the day of his
fight.
Played a guy named basketball game did.
That's a competitive do
and he's just an athlete.
Yeah,
I mean,
I just don't think there's any other way.
You know what I mean?
I think if you're going to win a race,
you're going to have red line the engine,
because I just don't see how
you're going to beat the best guy.
Everybody is trying their best.
This is the thing.
There's so much going on there.
I mean,
you could have like a really good coach,
so you have an advantage.
Technically you could have a really
good group of guys you train with so you
have an advantage in the environment
that you're training in and there's a lot
of inspiration.
But if you're not a fucking psychopath,
good luck.
Good luck.
I agree with you 100% man.
I mean,
I agree with you cause that's
how I ended up taking notes.
That's what I'm saying.
And I'm just letting,
I mean people who like wonder
why you're so fucking crazy.
Like what?
That's why he's so good.
There's no,
there's no other way around this game.
I appreciate it.
I mean,
listen man,
I appreciate it too.
I mean for me as a fan and as
a professional commentator,
you know,
this is,
it's important to me if there's not
people like you out there that are raising
the bar,
you know,
people like you and Henry,
so Hutto and just to,
you can go through the list of champions,
the great fighters that are around today.
This is the best time in the history
of the world to see martial arts.
There's never been better martial arts.
Never will the information
so easily accessible to us.
When I was wrestling as a kid.
Yeah,
you got like we're talking about drilling.
I remember being a kid and like drilling
the same move thousands of times.
She was like,
why are we doing this?
And you're so bored and I learned this,
you know,
but now I understand it'd be in a
profession how important it is and now how
easy like information.
Like for instance,
I created my fit to fight program,
like my online academy thing and I'm
showing techniques I've learned over my
whole entire
life and it created me
a year to create it.
But I'm giving you info like
think of when I was starting up.
I wish I could have learned from other
world champions just by going online or
when I was a wrestler.
If I want to learn same
Kalvia as a nutrition plan,
I can just go online and check it out.
You know he has a whole online program,
correct?
Yeah.
He has an APP.
He started called train champ and it's on,
is a website,
a training lab.com android and Iphone,
is it?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's uh,
it'll go through like
his workout routines.
It goes through the segmentation.
He puts me on,
it goes through,
it has a certain recipes that I've
been on throughout my fight camp.
The first one he created
was around rob me first.
Um,
because we've put so
much work in and go 25.
So we created a whole supplementation
diet plan at workout plan of what I did
and put it out there,
accessible for people.
I mean,
he even has a,
um,
you can even get a hair
analysis on his app.
You send in like they
send you a little kit,
you cut off on the back of your head
where your brainstem is that you cut off
your hair and you see me
where the brain's comes out.
That's really nutrition comes out at,
that's where all the nutrients for
immune nervous system will come through.
Fuck figured that out.
I don't,
they,
they burned the hair and
they get the toxins from it.
That's how I found out I have
too much arsenic in my body.
I feel you eating that
gave you that arsenic.
He thinks maybe the rice
or maybe my tattoos,
tattoos.
He thinks it's a really big tobacco.
Um,
there's a,
there's a lot of,
I mean since nick has begun tobacco
real so like if you chew yeah,
chewy.
I used to shoot,
I used to chew him college that
wouldn't it be still in your system.
Your body won't get rid of heavy metals
and as you make it year to heavy metals,
you have to do like a detox.
What do you do?
Uh,
so I juice,
I do a lot of juicing.
Um,
but as you,
uh,
like a quarter cup of Cilantro everyday
within all my juices I take us to lunch
row is effective in getting heavy
metals out of your system big time.
And same with Mathias burritos too.
Uh,
[inaudible] with juicing you get actually
absorb a lot more of the nutrients
when you cold press juice it
compared to just eating it.
I can eat a whole table of fruits and
vegetables and all absorb more of the
nutrients from it if I juice it
rather than just eating it raw.
Really interesting cause your body's
doesn't break it down the same.
But then I also take my thigh nine.
It's a,
I'm a thianine.
I don't know how to pronounce it,
but it's a amino,
the helps push out heavy metals.
Uh,
chlorella and Spirulina will
help push out heavy metals.
Um,
what else do you have me on?
I tested positive for our sneak back in
the day because I was eating too much.
Sardines.
Yeah,
they're heavy and sardines.
Yeah.
But all I did is just back off
the sardines and it went away.
They tested it again.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And you never tried pushing it out,
Huh?
And do shit.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Well how did you test it though?
Blood work.
So the blood work.
So that's one the difference.
So when you do your blood,
it's only right then in there.
What's in your body?
So when you,
like when you do your hormone levels,
you have to go in,
in the morning and your blood drawn
before you eat or drink anything because
it's what's in your body
right then and there.
But when you do a hair analysis,
it's what's in your body.
Like the last like nine months.
It's more,
it tells you more what's in
your actual body over time.
You know,
cause you might have just pushed arsenic
out of your blood rather than out of
your,
out of everything.
He's,
that's what he told me.
And he's a mathematician by trade.
Is that what he is?
He's a calculus teacher at a private,
uh,
private school.
Uh,
the world's pes calculus teacher,
he wants some award.
Um,
his kids that take the placement
test as advanced placement tests,
they all got 100%.
I think there's a,
I think there was a kid
that missed one question.
That's crazy.
Just one kid.
There's kids that travel all over the
world to come to his school because of his
accolades of being a Texas teacher.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean numbers never lie,
you know,
and I think that's what
it was always drawn to.
Like his,
his results and his
studies is always numbers.
Everything comes back to
the numbers of your body,
your hormone levels of my,
um,
heart rate variability.
Everything's done by numbers.
So,
wow.
So this is all a system
that he devised himself.
Did he mean,
does he have a background
in combat sports at all?
He wrestled.
So he wrestled at cal state Fullerton.
He was a big time wrestler and then
he was the world's strongest man.
Uh,
they did like that at Disneyland.
They used to do the world's strongest
man and he won for like the nation's
strongest man competition.
So he was huge.
He speak giant.
How much did he weigh?
Like two 60 to 80 and now
he's probably like 160.
170 pounds.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
he was giant.
Like you could stack a cup on his chest.
His chest was so big,
you know.
Um,
but I would never guess
that looking at him,
he looks like a Merrill Lynch.
He is now,
he does Iron Mans.
So he switched up.
He once he,
I keep,
so I think he had some health issues
from getting so big and being so strong.
He decided to switch things up and you
just got into his body because he started
doing iron mans and you want to
get better at being an iron man.
So really got into how to train himself.
And now he's done 14 iron mans.
He's qualified for Kona and eyes.
And you do Kona in October.
Wow.
How old is he?
Uh,
let's say 53 or 54.
Wow.
I think he just turned 54
still getting after it.
Yeah man.
Like he like every day.
I'm going to work out with him.
Yesterday he did and then uh,
when I got there he'll get in the garage
and he'll do like a two hour bike ride
and then we'd get on the treadmill and
he's always doing power intervals and
well he come in and do a podcast.
I can talk him,
do he?
He's a,
he's very,
he tries to hide everything he does.
He doesn't want his intellectual
value getting out there.
He puts a lot of work into it and I
think he'd be really good on your podcast
cause like some of the guys come in,
you're like,
information goes way over your head.
But it's nice to be able to listen
to it again and listen to it again.
I'd like to convince them to come on.
I think it'd be really interesting.
I don't know if he would.
He's a real shelter kind of guy.
What do you think it'd be easier to do?
Talk to Wayne and moving to California
or talk Kalvia to come down here.
Man.
I think maybe talking to I
need to come to California.
I don't know.
Um,
got to get them used to that beach life.
Yeah.
I mean he,
so he's been coming down like my fight
camp was 10 weeks long from with him I
was longer,
but with him it was 10 weeks and he
was flying out three days a week.
So every Monday he would land,
he would leave Wednesday night.
Wow.
And we were trained Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday and the hard right.
I make sure to take like Thursday off.
And then do my other
stuff while he's gone.
But every week he was
traveling back and forth,
spoke of litigation right there.
Dude,
I have a more family now.
You know,
like he's lived in my house,
like he's on the meal
plans with the cal vetoes.
Like he's full bore into it.
Like he gives me is all I'm,
I'm a very fortunate person that
I've met Dwayne and it's an amazing
relationship.
Our relationship.
Yeah.
How close it is.
It really is.
And I mean,
that's the ideal when you
can get a mentor and a in a,
a student that have that kind of a bond
together and you can learn so much.
Yeah.
And he won't let,
like we have such a good bond now too
that he won't like let bullshit slide
won't be pumping me up for no reason.
You won't like,
let me,
I mean,
I'm not a lazy guy,
but if I was,
he wouldn't let me like,
Miss Practice or,
you know,
I mean,
he almost has to pull me
back more than anything,
but,
uh,
he gives me,
this is true assessment
of what needs to be done.
Um,
I obviously lost the pseudo,
we got home and he has sent texts me.
He's like,
Hey,
I'm coming out tomorrow.
I'm going to work out with a wall,
but I'd love to get some working with you.
We just,
some things we should go over.
I was like,
all right.
So like I was working out with
him three days after the fight.
What did he say about that exchange?
Um,
he says like,
he,
maybe he needs a change and
things on the mits and maybe like,
so for instance,
the whole exchange,
uh,
I think I closed the distance too hard.
Henry pseudo switched up
who he was as a fighter.
I think he came out differently,
which was great by Hamm.
He's done great things.
He,
um,
I expected him to maybe run a little
bit more and you came out aggressive.
Um,
and so getting used to
the distance control,
you know,
not always having a set plan and,
and going for those Combos,
what I think's going to happen
to be able to adjust on the fly.
And maybe me and him.
Sometimes we are too set on
certain things whether than um,
reaction type stuff,
you know,
and I need to react to distance change.
I need to react to things like that.
It's hard to really change anything on
that fight because I didn't get a chance
to see it either.
You know,
it was so,
so quick.
Now do you,
have you talked to Dana or anyone since,
I know you said that you guys
would talk in the future,
but it's been about what,
how many days?
It's been about a week or so.
It's been two weeks,
but a week and a half.
It's been a week and a half now.
Yeah.
Um,
I haven't heard anything since the,
the day after the fight.
I was texting with him the day after the
fight and he said they had to sit down
and figure out what the
plane is kind of thing,
you know.
Um,
but obviously everyone knows
that we want to run it back and,
and it sounds like they do as well too,
so.
Well,
as far as something that
people want to watch,
whether it's at 35 or 25 I think people
absolutely would like to see that.
I mean at 35 the big selling point would
be Henry gets a chance to become champ
champ.
Of course,
they all fight him at 25 and put
my 35 pound belt on the line.
I really,
it works that way.
I know it doesn't,
but I'm saying like if
you beat me like I was,
I seriously like,
I wouldn't even tell him.
I seriously don't even care.
Like yeah,
the belts are awesome,
all that stuff in the revenue recognition,
all that stuff.
But to me I'd want that.
I want that one back.
I want that opportunity back to even just
show how much work in how smart I was
and how I didn't get,
I didn't get hit.
I wasn't fragile from being at 25.
Right.
I really wasn't like,
it wasn't like I didn't get beat
because I was at 25 pounder.
I would felt,
I have no excuses.
I got beat because I got beat.
Right.
I have no excuses that I was too fragile.
And being at one 25 is I felt better
than I've ever felt my entire life.
I just want the chance to prove that.
You know what I mean?
So that's why I say that I would give
them my belt at 35 big beats me up 20
fives again,
but well,
obviously take the fight wherever.
I mean,
I think Ali need Frazier,
right?
Your sugar.
I needed Tommy Hearns.
I mean this is just,
this is the nature of the
sport and a guy like him.
I mean,
I think you,
you and Cody needed each other.
Yeah.
I think there's something about that
kind of intense rivalry that is so
important for,
for,
for actualizing,
who knows a motherfucker,
man,
he's good and he's a,
he's a world is a Olympic gold medalist.
He's a competitor.
He knows what he's doing.
Right.
Let me just,
arguably from his accomplishments is one
of the greatest combat sports athletes
of all time.
The first guy ever to be an Olympic
gold medalist and a UFC world champion,
which I,
the gold medalist thing.
I even hold even higher for him than
even the a like obviously UFC champions
huge dry.
But I wrestled my whole life.
I grew up wrestling and to be an Olympic
gold medalists is a fucking huge thing.
Um,
I still think today wrestling is
the hardest sport I've ever done.
And just to see that achievement,
especially how young he
did it at and that's,
I almost hold that higher
than him being a UFC champion.
Well also the fact that he was beat by Dj,
he beat by beat by mighty
mouse in the first round.
He gets destroyed.
He gets need to the body,
taken out,
beaten up and stopped and humiliated,
right.
Comes back.
And what was it like two years later?
I think it was deep and beats him.
I mean becomes the fucking champ and
beats the pound for pound consensus.
Best fighter on the planet.
And the guy that had held that title
from the very first time it was ever
brought to the UFC.
He's been the only flyweight
champion until Henry came along.
So,
and that's another reason
why I want that fight,
man.
Like you know what I mean?
Like I know that I'm better than him.
Obviously.
You're going to give me some shit.
People are going to give me shit for
saying that because obviously the fight
they fail.
Think he went down the way it went down.
But guess what?
I'm better than that motherfucker
and I want to prove it.
I want the toughest fights.
I mean,
that's why I was calling out Max Holloway.
I wanted to,
I wanted to be Henry sued.
I don't want to call Max
Holloway with Sam Kalvia.
I can be walking around 165
pounds with 6% body fat,
you know,
100% like this guy,
man,
he can stack the weight on me.
You can take it off me.
I can go,
I have a secret weapon with Sam Kalvia.
I'm telling you.
And I could have started a secret.
He just,
yeah,
he blurred.
But people,
he won't work with everyone.
He won't do it.
Yeah.
If you come to them like
unless you fit who we,
he likes.
If he fit his image,
like what does it look like?
We worked out of his garage
that which is so crazy.
You know,
like he could have a giant facility
with all his hard work in science.
He does,
but he likes the,
the grit of having it in house.
Like he gets home from work,
he's all dressed up in his tie.
Sometimes we're already there waiting
for him and he's doesn't even change.
He's out there throwing medicine balls
that are facing his tie and I'll just up
from the soup from work,
you know,
like he likes that Shit,
not even be a calculus
teacher anymore and just be
a string conditioning coach.
But that's not what he wants.
You know,
he's not in it for the fame and the money.
He's in it for the science
and the love of doing it.
I want to see that garage get you pull it,
pull up his garage because this doesn't,
now I'm thinking about how big
my fucking gym out here is.
You couldn't even park two cars in it is,
it's a small garage.
We have one uh,
one squat rack.
We have a spot to do like our
cleans and are dead lifts.
What he really has his,
he has three,
four by,
I don't know,
three bite.
There it is.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So it's a very small two car garage
that has got filled with a bunch of
murderers.
Yeah.
He's got like three bikes and
we ride bikes or walking by.
If you were a girl,
I'll do all the time.
New People,
old people walk by all the time.
We're in the garage and I,
I'm yelling when I'm in there working
out cause he's pushing us like science.
So our workouts are three hours long,
you know,
and we're going,
there's a park across the street and we're
throwing medicine balls at each other
and go to that.
Back to that last one with Pico please.
Yeah.
You get a chance to see
what's in the garage.
So he,
I guess he parks his car in the driveway.
Oh yeah,
he doesn't,
he doesn't park.
That's the sanctuary man.
It's crazy.
And he's got the stationary
bikes in there that we were,
he kills us on.
That's like,
um,
how we push our lactate thresholds.
So what does he,
he's doing something
with bands right here.
Yeah,
that's true.
A lot of things with bands,
right?
Yeah.
Cause you get the east centric
and concentric contraction.
You know,
you have a straight and he's
like what he's doing it.
There's for your shoulder stability,
your rotator cuffs.
I mean with the Jujitsu and the wrestling,
your shoulders take a beating.
Yeah.
So that's kind of really
just strengthen it.
Yeah.
I do a lot of cough stuff because,
well all the different
injuries that I've had,
I do a lot of band stuff with my,
you know,
like this way,
the external rotation,
internal rotation stuff.
Bands are great.
Now why bands though as a
PR as opposed to cables,
cables with a stacks.
Wait,
why does he use bands pad?
Just what's what we have.
I mean,
if he had a nice Kaiser machine in there,
maybe we'd use it.
But I think,
um,
the resistance coming back really,
really wants to pull the
further you extend a band,
the harder it wants to pull you back to
where when you have a weight on there,
it's the exact same weight going in and
out toward the further you extend that
band,
the harder you make it on yourself.
There's,
I think there's just more you can do
with it and it's just very easy and it
takes up no space.
Right.
We do a lot of medicine ball work,
um,
for our core and for our
shoulders as well too,
like catching and weird angles
with keeping our balance.
Um,
we do like a lot of like
kind of like old school shit,
but in a certain way.
In a certain time.
Yeah.
And so how does he get all
that shit into his garage?
Does he have to pull stuff
out into the driveway?
There's stuff on the side of his house.
He's got like a little Chessy
stack stuff into and um,
man,
we,
a lot of it's,
it doesn't need much.
He really doesn't.
And there's a,
there's a lot of work you can do,
which is body weight that,
I mean we have a hundred
pound medicine balls,
we've got these big logs
and he makes it like,
it's almost like a
strong man competitions.
There's a big,
there's a big hill next to his house
that he makes his carry these 800 pound
logs and we have to farmer's carry
him up the hill and we're doing with a
partner.
And when I get up so far I dropped him,
I run back,
I get the hundred pound medicine ball
at the sprint up the hill with it.
Things like that where
you're pushing your,
your lactate threshold over time.
Wow.
Yeah.
And how does he schedule the,
the training sessions?
Like how does he know what to have you do
when?
Off of our timeframe of when we want a
peak off of my heart rate variability and
how my body's reacting to our training.
Cause maybe I sparred and I
admits too hard with Dwayne.
So I wake up the next
morning and he realizes,
oh we've got to pull back today.
Like if I push you hard today,
you're going to go in such a deep hole
that's going to take you a week to come
out of it to where he only wants
me to get to that really high peak,
take a day off so that now I can start
coming back up again to where if I just
continue for four or five days,
just crushing it,
run as hard as I possibly can.
My body is going to crash so
hard that's going to take me,
it's going to be more of a
detriment to come out of that hole.
Then if I would have just taken a
break in between those days so he'll,
he'll sketch.
There are schedules will change.
We have a,
we have a schedule from the beginning,
so Sam,
12 weeks out.
Like,
all right,
this is our planet.
So what we're going to do,
but then maybe I get sick
or maybe I trained too hard
with Dwayne the day before
and so he'll realize all right,
this next day was a little bit easier.
Even if it's my Jujitsu,
he knows I'm going to do to practice.
He's like,
maybe just drill,
you know,
go with fleet page.
Just make sure it's like a low base drill.
Like don't get your heart
rate over such and such.
Which I don't roll with
a heart rate monitor on,
but I can kind of just guess.
You know how hard I need to go.
Could you,
I guess you could say,
hey buddy,
do you know anybody that does now it
seems like it would get knocked off or
something like that.
I mean maybe for drilling.
Yeah.
So when he's got you doing all this crazy
stuff like dead lifts and plateaus and
medicine ball work,
um,
does,
is there like a logic to what exercises
are done when and like how does he like,
cause it seems like you're doing all
this old school stuff like bad ass stuff.
But my question is always like,
when do you do that?
When is that,
when is that done?
Like once a week.
Is that done early in the training camp?
Is it done late?
Like when are you doing
strength work and your,
cause you were saying you were
doing cleans like the week out.
Only a,
so when I'm doing those like a week out,
I'm doing them only a
certain amount of reps.
Um,
you know,
I'm not,
maybe not taxing my body for as long as
I would an earlier camp and even though
I'm going heavy,
maybe I'm only doing two sets,
you know,
just to keep my central nervous system
strong because other than just taxing
yourself,
you know,
are there certain times like
there's certain days he needs,
I need to get explosive power work
or some days I needed you cadence,
fast,
fast feet,
um,
cardio work and he has that all
mapped out on what days or what,
what weeks are what depending on where
I'm at my fight camp or if I'm going 20
fives and if I want to stay
as strong as it was at 35,
things like that.
Or if I end up going 45,
um,
to be able to keep my,
my,
my cardio up.
Because the thing was if I were,
if I would go 45,
I'm gonna have to put so much more muscle
on the worry that I'm going to lose
cardio.
Right.
And nobody wants to be able to
keep that lactate threshold.
And me keep my cardio if I'm able
to walk around at 165 pounds.
Now,
what other stuff does he
have you doing for recovery?
You doing any sauna work?
Are you doing ice baths?
Like what kind of stuff?
I have an infrared sauna.
I do,
I'm a do red light therapy.
I do.
Um,
uh,
what do you mean by red light therapy?
There's a machine that I have
in my house is called a a juve.
It's um,
a big red light.
It says 680 to 880 nanometer light that
I stand in front of it for a certain
amount of time to,
um,
not only increase my testosterone,
but to help recovery and my,
uh,
I Mitochondria and my cells
and flushing my body out.
Um,
uh,
what was the thing look like?
Whoa.
Look at that dude.
You're in the future.
Yeah.
Is that,
you know,
it's jacked.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
I have one of those in my garage.
I have a infrared sauna in my garage.
Um,
I do that thing.
Well there's new ones now that are huge.
I gets as big as my body.
Um,
that one's that go on
the back of your door.
They have travel ones you can take
with you that it's really small.
The reason why I got into it was for,
uh,
increasing my dishwasher on the moon
and the motility of my sperm Holla.
Yeah.
Cause I was,
I was,
I was having,
um,
my question was low and I wanted
to increase it and I saw this,
um,
through Matt Brown,
actually,
Matt Brown is the one that Kinda
got me this when I was at Colorado.
Shout out to the man,
he's got some awesome training equipment.
He's,
and he's a very knowledgeable,
very well read guy and a,
you wouldn't like pure and guests
that when I had him on the podcast,
that's one of the things
a lot of people said.
They go,
I thought that the guy was a caveman.
I write kind of is,
he's also kind of brilliant.
He wants to be the caveman like manly man.
But he's very smart about,
um,
so he's the one that turned me on to that.
And so I got into it and,
uh,
I wanted to increase my
testosterone but also read about,
um,
increasing motility of my sperm.
I was trying to have a kid and we're
having trouble and this and that.
And it could be,
that could have been my diet.
I switched so much up that I
can't tell you which one it was.
You know,
cause Sam helped me out.
This helped me out.
I mean,
so I'm doing that.
I'll do hyperbaric chamber.
I'll do cryotherapy.
How often do you do
the hyperbaric chamber?
Um,
only when I need it because
it can mess with your,
um,
your hematocrit.
You know,
if I'm going to do a lot of
altitude training as well too,
I'm trying to increase my red
blood cell count and my hematocrit.
Um,
and then when you go and you
get in to a hyperbaric chamber,
you're breathing 100% oxygen.
So if I'm in it too much
lower my hematocrit right.
But I do a lot of,
he has,
he has the altitude.
Same as an altitude machine he
has me used is called Alto lab.
Um,
I breathe it into it for a certain
amount of time and it's again,
another program he created.
The company was around,
but he created the program that I'm
supposed to do to put my body in a hypoxic
state for only a certain amount of time
because you can overtrain yourself that
way as well to um,
to increase my capillaries,
um,
uh,
increased the date of
vasodilation and my veins
as well as increase red blood increase,
increased red blood cells.
That's amazing because you know,
one of the things that's a big,
um,
well I don't know if it's a misconception,
but it's one of the things that people
always talk about is that you should
train at altitude and you did that,
you went to Denver and a lot of people
do that and they find benefits in that.
But the thought process now seems to
be that you get more worked on it.
C level EXEC.
So I thought the same thing.
And then I met Sam and I,
and I actually felt this it and understand
it that your body can't recover the
same or he can't push as hard at altitude.
And your body actually gets a more dance
at sea level when you're working out,
are you able to push harder
and your recovery is better?
Um,
and same reason why I think sleeping in
and out to two went and help either Q
because your body won't
recover a completely.
Um,
so I feel better training at sea level,
but I use this alto lab for only a
certain amount of time on and off with
breathing techniques.
And I felt the best of the
best benefits with that.
So what does this thing look like?
You see pope,
it's a so loud.
I was just a mask and it's got a bunch
of cylinders on it and the more cylinders
you stack on it,
the more it's a emulating the,
uh,
the altitude.
So it's like breathing at 40,000 feet
when you stack a lot of them on there.
And,
um,
so you're,
you're hooked up to this thing
how breathing gas mask on it?
Yeah.
You could use that word.
It's just like a snorkel,
right?
Or it could be a gas mask kind of thing.
And you're doing it while you're training?
No,
no,
not doing it while I'm training,
I'm doing it while I'm
resting on certain days,
like a certain schedule.
I can't do it all the time.
This thing without training,
this thing jacks up your,
your cardio.
Yes it will.
It'll help with your,
what do I buy one of these?
I'll tell that you just,
you just breathe.
Yeah.
But I'd have to give you the,
the,
um,
technique because you can overdo it as
well and you can end up hurting yourself
as well too.
And how long do you do it?
Four.
It says here,
10 minutes or 60 minutes.
And then there's a program,
initial 15 day program and our breathing
session will produce performance
affects that lasts up to three weeks.
Jesus.
Wow.
So for a 60 minute sessions,
six 10 minutes sessions,
10 minutes.
What's wrong with my voice?
It's six 10 minute sessions or 10,
six minutes on,
four minutes off.
So six,
six per hour.
And so you're basically doing these
intervals where you're just breathing.
Yeah.
And it's one of those things.
So you have a,
you have a auction,
um,
reader on your finger.
It tells you your oxygen levels because
you want to put yourself in a hypoxic
state and there's certain levels up.
Sam wants me to keep my body,
I just want me to go too low either
because your body will start producing a
hormone that tells you you're dying.
Oh Geez.
Yeah,
and I've
won Archeletta when I first met him I was
coaching the ultimate fighter came out
and told me,
he's like,
hey man,
I've been breathing this thing.
Sam tells me to do it.
I'm like,
all right,
what do I do?
He's like,
just get your levels as low as you can.
Cool.
I ended up passing out cause he had,
so I'm,
I'm,
you know me,
I'm very competitive,
right?
And I was like,
I was looking at it and you're
supposed to do for six minutes.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I've got like 30 seconds left.
But it's getting hard.
Like I can make it the rest 30 seconds.
Next thing I remember,
I'm like seizuring on a couch.
I fling this auction unmonitored off
my finger and then I wake up a couple
minutes later I'm like,
Oh shit.
I passed out,
you know,
so wow.
You could,
yeah.
You don't want to do too much.
Yeah.
A 40,000 feet seems a little excessive.
Oh yeah.
But it seems like it would
be amazing for hikers to,
or someone who does want to climb
Everest or something like that.
Get yourself to a person that started,
I think they started it for some sort
of disease and obviously everyone runs
with it for um,
getting better results through it.
I'm buying once those motherfuckers,
if I can get better
endurance just sitting here.
But it's work though,
Dude.
Like you'll end up oh yeah,
you'll sweat it too.
Yeah.
So it's just because it's hard
to breathe with the thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
so you want to get a yeah,
I mean you're not getting it.
Sometimes I'll have to like pull off
and get some fresh air and get back onto
it.
Like you want to keep your levels that,
cause you want to go too low.
It can,
you'll pass out.
And is it a breathing exercise?
Like are you doing anything?
Are you pushing or you learn?
Yeah.
You learn how to breath
of fire type stuff.
You've learned how to get the carbon
dioxide out of your body as well too.
Like you really learn a
lot about breathing when
you're doing this sink cause
you have the oxygen monitor on your
finger and when you want to increase your
oxygen levels,
I'll let more air out.
Right?
But if I want to decrease
my oxygen levels faster,
I'll take shallow breaths and I could
learn that I can get my body in a hypoxic
state faster by doing it.
But then when I need to like
get more oxygen in my body,
I'll make sure to excel more than carbon
dioxide and then breathe in more air.
So you kind of,
it does teach you how to
breathe better as well too.
And then you're creating more capillaries,
more lung strength,
a lot of stuff.
So it's going to be mad at me
for probably talking about that.
Yeah,
no.
Are you breathing in through your nose?
You're breathing through your mouth.
I have my mouth by nose closed.
Pinched off.
Is your nose functional?
Not so good.
All right,
well let's as good.
Yeah,
my rights.
Most fighters,
right sides.
I mean I'm a mouth breather.
When have you ever thought
about getting an opened up?
I have,
but I was told that um,
for me to get it done,
she's going to happen again.
Like it'll,
it'll,
it'll weaken the structural integrity
and my nose and cause they got to like
carve out the cause my nose insights
just crooked so they'd have to carve it
out.
And so they say that it'll just happen
and I'll have to get it done again.
So I had it done.
It was one of the best
things I've ever done.
I haven't seen that flag,
but it's one of the best
things I've ever done.
Ready.
That sounds so good.
Like I'll be in yoga.
I've been doing yoga the last like four
days because I've been trying to keep my
weight down and they'll make you breathe
in through your nose and I'm just in
the back of the house and
you're trying to breathe in.
It's the worst.
When I used to do yoga
for how to fix that,
guy would tell me breathe three no's.
I'm like,
I don't,
my basically don't have a nose.
You can fart my face.
I barely smell it.
This thing's useless.
Yes,
exactly.
That.
I hate being a mouth
breather at night too.
I wake up in the morning
with like the driest worst.
Well,
I mean it's just part of the part
of the struggle,
right?
Yeah.
So a cryotherapy.
How often are you doing that?
Um,
when I have the time,
I mean Sam's,
all the same stuff and the
training I do is a full time job,
more than a full time job.
And so it takes a lot.
Um,
depending on how much recovery I need.
we're looking to open up her own gym and
putting her own crowd therapy in it so
I can use it more often.
Looking to team up with a company that
wants to join forces with us and come
into our gym and where they have
hyperbaric chambers on hand,
which I owned my own,
but I haven't been using it
because I haven't had hooked up.
Um,
what do you,
what company are you going
with right now because of you?
You have you gone to Cryo healthcare?
They have the best fucking
crowd is there's like a room
or is it like the little
one's room isn't the room one is the one
you want because the little room one is
cold air.
Okay.
You know the woman who died in Vegas,
you know,
store,
she worked at a cryo place and
she did it herself unfortunately.
And she had it adjusted wrong and so
it was like below her nose and she was
breathing in this stuff and she
blacked out and froze to death.
She was working there
by herself unsupervised.
You're never supposed to do that.
He never supposed to climb it in
one of those things on supervisors,
I would have never guessed the one.
They haven't cryo healthcare.
It's not liquid nitrogen that you,
that's on your body.
It's cold air.
So they're freezing the
air with liquid nitrogen.
And this is it right here.
I took a Davidson Claire who's a,
um,
he's a professor at Harvard and one
of the leading guys in the longevity
movement.
And I took them there the other day.
It's,
uh,
you walk in that chamber and you know,
you,
you take,
you put a little mask on your face and
earmuffs on just to stop frost by 240
degrees.
I'll take you there right now if you want.
Yeah,
we'll do it right.
We have,
we get out of here man.
Yeah.
It's the shit.
You're in there for
three minutes and it's,
so I've done the below
the neck and it's hard.
Yeah.
It's like God,
it's cold but it's nothing like this
thing cause your fucking head is frozen.
I don't feel like those are the ones that
have stayed in like three minutes when
you're talking about a very hard,
exactly.
Yeah.
Yes.
I'm glad.
Nice down there.
Yeah.
There's that.
There's a company called o two
that wants to team up with us.
Like I said,
they have red light therapy.
Even you do have crowded therapy.
Where do float tanks?
I'm sorry,
I was listening to your
podcast a while ago.
Beautiful.
And do that seriously.
For me.
It's like the only form of meditation
I can get because otherwise I have too
much stuff going on.
I have my phones,
I got people asking me to do this.
People ask me to do that like I have.
It's awesome cause you go in there and
you have to like get rid of everything.
I usually fall asleep.
I usually go in there for the most part
I help maybe like 30 minutes I'll be
there and relax.
I'll be like meditating,
thinking about stuff and then
eventually I will wake up like,
oh damn,
I fell asleep.
If you're ever around this area.
I got one right there.
You can climb at anytime you want.
I would love to text me.
Okay,
I'll open it up.
They have a chin here,
man.
It's this one right here.
The float lab version.
Have you seen this one?
Have you seen the one?
I have.
No fucking huge.
It's giant.
It's like you can't touch
the tall nine feet long.
No slouch.
It's enormous and the guy
who had credit who made it,
this guy crash,
he's the reason why they're
high level tanks today.
He's a mad scientist and he's the
guy who was behind the float lab.
When you see how extensive the
purification system this guy has,
he's got like water purification systems
that you would use for commercial
purposes,
like for a fucking,
like a,
a block,
like a city block and it's
just for this one tank.
It's crazy.
And it's probably a pretty expensive,
it's very expensive and he's
a maniac and so he makes the,
these insanely overdeveloped tanks.
And when I first got into tanks was around
2000 you had these like kind of thin
plastic ones,
which were fine.
They worked.
I had one in my basement,
but then it busted and the
w the water spilled out.
I had a fucking get my basement drained.
It was a nightmare.
And the guy who was fixing the
tank told me about the float lab,
which is,
they have a place in Venice,
in a place in Westwood.
And uh,
they were fucking,
this whole spa,
the whole industry was dying.
It was going away and
I didn't understand it.
I was like,
how is this so awesome?
But no one,
no one knows.
It was too much so,
well it wasn't that.
It was just nobody tried it.
Nobody knew about it.
I didn't try and tell you,
I heard you on a podcast do,
I can't shut the fuck up about it.
I just,
I love it.
It's amazing.
It's still,
I mean my life is crazy.
I'm sure everyone's life
is crazy minds insane.
I have too much shit
going on all the time.
So it's like seriously one of the
only ways I can shut my brain off.
It's the only time you were alone with
just your thoughts where your bodies
aren't even there.
So as that's the reason why I like to
take a shit cause I by myself like my
shit's had been like three times
longer cause I give it to him.
I tell him like Ah yes,
no one know what the key to taking a good
shit as though don't bring your phone.
I know it's the hottest thing.
You bring your phone,
you start scrolling through Instagram
looking at girls butts and fucking
explosions like oh where's my phone?
I got to think of Shit.
Exactly.
My kids know I grab that phone and
I started walking to the bathroom,
go,
oh,
that's going to be there for a while.
Then you too,
man.
It's the worst.
I bet a cell phones
have created the him uh,
triple the hemorrhoids.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
right.
For sure.
They long you sit on the toilet
now compared to what you used to.
Eddie Bravo has very extensive theories
on creating hemorrhoids on the toilet.
Like about what is happening to your ass.
Ask Him.
Oh,
he goes into great detail
about the pressure of the bowl,
that it's an unnatural pressure,
like squeezing part of your ass and
this part is creative toilet seat.
Then he created his own toilet
seat to get rid of hemorrhoids.
Really?
The move is those squatty potty.
Oh Dude.
I have one of those.
It's like,
whoa.
I didn't know how much in there.
It's just,
whew.
He comes flying out.
I seen you had a,
is that a toto in here?
Dude?
I think that makes the,
um,
what does it Braun del Bron down?
I think those are the shit.
I built the house out in Colorado
and I put one of those in my,
I don't want to shit anywhere else.
Yes,
exactly.
It's like,
do I just only want to go home and take
a shit cause that until it seats way
better and it's got the
day and it's awesome.
So do you rent your house out in Colorado?
No.
Just go out there and visit when you can.
Um,
kind of like a little vacation house now.
I mean,
I live in,
I live in Orange County,
um,
but a lot love Orange County.
I do,
man.
It's nice out there.
I went to school down there and went
to school at cal state Fullerton.
So all my close friends I wrestle with
are in the same part of their life that
all of young kids,
they're all,
they're all in the same area.
So it's,
and not only that,
my family's close.
I love Orange County.
It's definitely been
a great change for me.
But,
uh,
Colorado's beautiful.
How far are you from the beach?
Uh,
probably a half hour.
That's not too bad.
No,
about a half hour from Huntington,
Newport.
So,
yeah,
it's,
it's nice.
It's a,
it's a suit.
I mean,
Yorba Linda is like a family area too.
It's like such a nice little cool area.
It's very nice.
Yeah.
That whole area is nice in Kalvia is out
in that area to tell via lives in Yorba
Linda.
One lives in Yorba Linda.
Cub lives in Yorba Linda,
so we got a good little,
like a little family started there.
All the guys that wrestled with
and college live in the area.
Well,
it's nice to see guys from both
organizations with the UFC and bell toward
training together too.
I mean,
I've seen that with you guys.
I mean Beltour really now is like,
it's a major player then
they have like major,
major talent.
Absolutely.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
I mean they don't get as much credit.
Obviously they're not those big promotion,
but they have some of the best fighters,
you know,
they got,
I mean,
look,
they've got gay guard moved sauce,
you know,
like a Rory Macdonald Macdonald.
Yeah.
You can go down the list.
How about fucking Ryan Bader?
Keown Fitzroy that crazy.
I thought Bader was going to win.
I thought it was going to use this
pressure and just wear on him and route
wrestle him.
Um,
but yeah,
that's crazy.
10 seconds while he clipped him with that.
Crazy.
It's like a level chance.
Yeah.
Level Change.
Half Hook,
Half Jab.
I think he was getting fade or to think
that he was in dropped for a shot and
loop to hook over the time.
Right.
It seemed like he wanted
to get fade or to do that.
Isn't that how I got the knockout?
The fight before that too,
right,
exactly.
Same Punch took.
Yeah.
It was a level change leftover.
You know,
people are thinking like,
oh shit,
he's coming for a takedown.
Well,
as a heavyweight man,
he's a motherfucker.
He looks good,
he looks fantastic.
Body looks good.
Yeah.
I mean he looks like a heavyweight.
And you know,
he's weighing two 35 ish,
somewhere around there,
you know,
which is a great weight for heavyweight.
I think it's the best way
for that weight class.
There's that point of diminishing returns.
Right?
You get to like two 60
unless you're in Ghana.
Well,
let's see,
in Ghana who doesn't know how to wrestle,
so that's part of the problem.
But,
but if he did holy fuck,
but as a,
as an agile,
as you needed to beat wrestle,
I don't know if he could move that fast.
He can move fast.
Muesli or cat.
Damn.
He scares the shit out of me because guy,
if he knew like what everybody else knew,
I just think he's so physically gifted.
Yeah.
I mean when you see him punch people
it's like it's a different thing.
It's different.
Yeah.
Just a lunchbox coming at your head.
The power is just preposterous.
It just doesn't even make any sense.
Yeah.
If that guy could get with a guy like
Dwayne and start moving and just,
you know,
not just rely on throwing hammers but
set and stuff up and switching stances.
I don't know if you can do
that with kind of weight,
you know?
How long can a guy like that move,
you know,
my brother Sam can get
him to move that along.
I Jane Tease,
you'd say,
I'm like,
I'm telling you,
like if I'm going like for my body mass,
if I'm able to walk around with
65 and the lactate threshold,
he's telling me I can
have a guarantee you,
you can do it with the big guy like that.
Wow.
That would be insane.
Well,
there's not a lot of big guys like that.
That's the thing too.
It's like who does he have to train with?
It's going to push him.
Yeah.
You know,
the I,
that is a giant problem with heavyweights,
whether it's in wrestling
or Jujitsu or anything,
it's finding someone that
they could train with.
It's that heavy.
If it's that big,
I mean he's,
he's a legit natural 265 pound man.
And I mean,
well,
I feel like if you're getting
hit by another 265 pound man too,
it's going to take more out of you.
Even if you're to 65 and you're getting
hit by under the guise to 65 I still
feel like your head can only take so much.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
how much more can you take?
Right?
Yeah.
I mean this is,
that's the football thing that we were
talking about when we're talking about
Jason Harrison.
He was alignment for
Uc Davis and you know,
played a little bit in the
NFL was a bench warmer,
but you know,
it was training with those guys.
It's just that,
that you're dealing with gigantic
huge dudes slamming anyway.
Tried to like that.
The force.
Yeah,
I guess you got to do more of like the
journal and what we're talking about are
live like live drilling.
You know where you're going with like
partners that you can trust that you're
going to do 50% sparring here,
not to crush each other,
but you're going to get that
reaction time kind of stuff.
But then you can wrestle hard.
You could use your,
get too hard and get that,
that hard training that way,
but then drill the right ways.
Striking,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Now,
um,
as far as your recovery stuff,
did you detail everything here?
You've got the red light,
you have your infrared sauna
using like one of those fits spas,
which would cause I think it is a fit spa.
Is that the kind that has like a TV in it?
No,
it's got,
it's got Bluetooth for listening to your
podcasts and he's got it's infrared.
So it's,
it's,
it's got the red light on
and gets to 140 degrees.
Right.
But uh,
the infrared makes you sweat
from this cells inside out,
which I feel is better for the recovery.
Um,
I do like to super hot ones,
like they do something to you that like,
um,
it's hard to describe
when you get out of it.
Like when it's really
hot and you feel great,
but I feel like I get more recovery
out of the infrared throughout my body.
Same reason why I use the
Juve red light therapy.
Um,
ice baths.
No,
I don't do ice pass their torture.
I've done the Cryo and again too,
I don't do that much of it.
Um,
I think mainly I needed to get,
I get my recovery from,
uh,
taking the days off.
I need to most of my recovery,
like a,
I take,
I take more days off now working with
Sam than I've ever taken in my past.
Um,
when I was working with Dwayne
out in Colorado or at Alpha Male,
I would just go,
go,
go.
I thought working more was interviewed me,
they're better.
And that's probably why your testosterone
was dropping a hundred percent.
I was red land in myself and so I
take more days off now with Sam,
but the days that I'm not
taking off for a lot harder,
um,
just knowing when to cycle those days off,
like you have to rest and I hate my sleep.
Um,
I have a one year old,
so I created a guest room that I'll sleep
in during camp cause I got to get my
nine hours of sleep.
Um,
and know what days I gotta take off.
and uh,
those days will be off
from training completely.
I'll try to like go take my son on a walk,
go hang out with my family.
Um,
obviously I got less of that,
this camp because I'm going 20 fives.
It took a lot more work.
Um,
but it's making sure
to take those days off.
What about massage?
Yes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
How often do you do that?
As much as I can.
I mean,
I'll do it.
I don't think you can do too much of
it as long as you've got someone that's
knowledgeable,
um,
massage big time.
Some were you connect and I said another
way to really relax and shut the brain
off to.
Yeah.
Um,
anything to get my really,
your recovery needs to be
dropping your cortisol levels.
If you could drop your cortisol levels,
everything else is going
to go the way it should go.
Um,
which is another thing I test throughout
my campus and my cortisol levels.
You know,
maybe I'm doing too much
outside of training,
like too much a sponsorship stuff
or my fit to fight program or old.
My other businesses,
my flavor republic by
the way is excellent.
Uh,
tell people about this stuff.
This stuff is really good.
You said a while back.
Yeah.
Got some great rubs.
This is a honey garlic.
It's all healthy stuff.
It's called flavor of public.
This is not,
I mean,
this is a plug folks,
but I'm not getting paid for this.
I just love,
I love it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great stuff,
man.
When I got into it,
because I met a,
um,
a Jujitsu guy,
he's really,
his name's Kenny tinny.
He's really big into Jujitsu.
He was taking Propecia
and it messed up his,
on one level.
We're talking about this before
the show did the same thing to me.
Yeah.
It messed up his testosterone levels.
So he had to get into his diet to kind
of recurve what he had going on because
he was taking insane,
insane amounts of therapeutic level
of testosterone to get his body back.
Um,
and so he wanted to get
his diet on point to,
so we wouldn't have to take as much test.
Um,
and as well as I teamed up
with just an average Joe.
He's just a guy that wants to get
into fitness and wants to be healthy,
but us three,
we created this because I got into my
diet so much because I'm not eating any
sugars.
I don't go complex.
I'm pretty much going like Paleo Keto and
saw and every time I wanted to do meal
prep or Sam wanted to do meal prep,
we couldn't use spices and seasonings
because if you look on the shelf,
they have like 14 grams of
sugar and a bunch of tables.
We were talking about trigger.
I love triggers grills and I love the
rubs and their barbecue sauces and
everything so good.
But there's some fucking
sugar in that shit.
A lot of so Delecia.
Exactly.
And so we created this so that we could
do our meal prep and still be healthy.
You know an espresso rug that's
really good on your a wild game.
Yeah.
It's really,
it's,
it's like a,
it's like a peppery kick.
That one doesn't sell very well because
I think it's called Espresso Rub.
People don't realize,
understand it.
Espresso blend.
So it doesn't need to change
like a Colombian something,
you know,
like,
cause they're like coffee.
I don't think that's it.
I don't know man.
We were talking about with
Ben Greenfield yesterday,
coffee rubs are fantastic.
Awesome.
He was saying that coffee actually reduces
the amount of carcinogens on cooked
meat.
Oh really?
Yeah,
like having it on the outside that it
acts as an antioxidant and reduces the
amount of carcinogens.
First Time I tried it was a,
um,
a piece of meat.
I got whole foods and it
had an espresso rub on it.
Amazing.
So like we need to make that like I'm
telling you like all the wild game I have,
like it takes away any
of the Gamey flavor.
Let's get that.
It doesn't sell as well because
people don't understand,
but it's really good.
Are you getting any hunting in?
Do you have any time?
I did this year and nothing successful.
Um,
after my Cody fight in August,
I went out in the middle of nowhere
in Colorado by this park and hunted by
myself.
I did like a nice getaway.
Huh?
Duty with my phone.
Didn't work.
No one can text me holding me.
I slept out in the middle of the
wilderness by myself under the stars.
Kind of freaky.
I've never done that before,
you know.
Um,
but I endorse him was
telling me about that,
that it was like,
you gotta do it.
It's like,
it's one of the best
things I've ever done.
I like hunting with people cause you
get to get like really to know them.
Right.
Like,
you know,
sit around the campfire,
everyone and it splits up to go
hunt and you talk about your day,
you get back to the campfire and you,
you really get to know each other.
And I go with my brothers
and my dad all the time.
We use one of my favorite
things about hunting.
It's the best it really is.
And you were like really get to tell
stories and get to know each other.
It's awesome.
But I went by myself for the first time
this year and that was an experience as
well too.
Like you got like just the hunting on
and doing it like the wilderness by
yourself.
Like making sure you
don't get lost three days.
So did you backpack in?
Yeah.
Oh No,
I got to drive in.
It wasn't,
so I went to a trailhead.
Yep.
And how much you carry on when your back?
Uh,
probably like 40,
50 pounds.
So you got like a day pack and like,
yeah,
I got that.
Um,
and then I'll just hike back in.
And you have a bow?
My bow.
Yeah.
I,
I really only liked to hunt with my bow.
I will do some rifle.
Oh,
just when the opportunity comes.
But you have time to practice with my bow.
I do,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's kind of another
escape for me as well too.
Like another way,
like maybe my off day,
like my days it co coach
tells me to take a day off.
Maybe I'll go shoot my bow or from in
Colorado I would take my boat out or go
fishing,
things like that.
So that's one of my hobbies.
Like even if I'm not getting
ready for hunting season,
I'll just shoot just to shoot.
Next time you come here you've
got to play techno hunt.
Is this the one out here in front
of you haven't seen that yet,
Huh?
I've,
I've played it.
I've played it at an
archery shop in Colorado.
It's like a three d hunting.
It's a video game pretty much.
And you shoot like these
magnets at the screen.
Well,
it's not a magnet.
It's just a flat broadhead.
It's flat like a ahead of a nail.
Yeah,
it's cool.
And it's a Kevlar screen.
It's very realistic too.
It gives you a score if you get like a
vital shot or if you wound the animal.
Exactly.
That's cool.
Yeah,
for sure.
I'll have to bring my boat next time.
It's super addictive.
I mean,
you've got the fantasy factory here,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't even know if I'd
go home if I had this place.
Now I've got a bunch of
stuff here for my kids.
Oh really?
So yeah.
It's like,
do you see that inflatable
thing out their mouth?
That was just a judge.
How far you're shooting for now?
No,
that's bouncing things off.
Filled up with air.
My a 10 year old comes in here and
does fucking backflips and show with a
concrete around it.
She's a fucking freak.
Really doesn't care.
I'd be scared of Shit.
This is like,
it's like not very why he got to let them,
you gotta let them do wild shit.
Well there's the mats out
there to the Jujitsu match.
She does him on that too.
Okay.
It shows gymnastics.
Yeah.
That's hard on your body.
It is.
Yeah.
I have,
when I wrestled the,
we had a gymnastics team and they
were always in the physical therapy.
They were always hurt their backs,
their any case.
So I think 10 year olds it's like first
of all I just see the shit she does like
she could stand here and take our
hands and touch the back of her ankles.
She has bends all the way back and it's
like well how the fuck your body even
work that way.
I look at this 51 year old fucked up body
of mine from all the years of beating
on it and it's like,
but all the,
all the weightlifting you do
is make you stiff for too,
I mean all the years,
the door not knowing what I was doing,
just lifted me head style
and then just get like,
like right now I'm training with Sam
and we're going heavy just to keep my
weight.
We don't know.
I don't know if we're going 35 I
don't know if I'm going on 25 45 or,
yeah,
I'm just keeping my weight where it
needs to be and getting a lot stronger.
So he's telling me like,
we're adding all this muscle,
make sure you're doing your yoga.
And that's,
that's why I've been doing that as well.
The other thing I wanted to talk
to you about outside of Yoga,
are you doing stretching?
Yes.
Yeah.
How often do you guys trunk
who I stretched before every,
I do a dynamic stretch before every
practice before practice is interesting
because most people don't,
don't,
we'll statics that don't do stat.
I don't like doing static
stretching before I work out.
That dynamic.
You're constantly moving
while you're stretching?
Yes.
It's something I've learned from Lauren.
Then out in Colorado and something I've
added to my fit to fight program as I go
through like a whole dynamic warmup
that I do before every practice.
It's like a walking series,
you know,
like a walking knee hug,
a walking home,
quad pole inchworms like things like that.
And like a quadro pet series.
It'll keep my hips loose,
things like that.
I'll do that before every practice.
Um,
but then at the end of practice
you do a little bit of a,
I don't do as much static stretching.
I do more dynamic kind of
like in movement stretching,
you know,
same thing as like,
I mean I get more flexible.
I got so much more flexible when I started
kickboxing just from that throwing a
head kick,
throwing a head kick and just
opening your hips all the time.
But before I throw a bunch of head kicks,
I needed to do my quadro series to
not mess my hip flexors up or my my,
so as we'll get tight as shit,
you know,
some more of those.
So rights.
Do you have one of the,
I heard Chandler talking
about that one for you.
Yeah,
I've got a gang of them really as a
sponsor so they can be a bunch of them is
the shit and you lay on it,
right?
Yeah.
You can do all kinds of things.
It hurts.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
it hurts.
But it works.
Cause I had a,
silver has messed up for one of my
fights before my Joe Soto fight,
I couldn't throw a kick.
So two weeks before the
fight I couldn't throw kicks.
I was like,
fuck man.
Like my bad.
I thought it was my back.
My lower back was toast.
I was like,
I had a massage therapist working
on my backwards on my back.
And then finally I got some,
I was like,
no dude,
it's your so as,
and they started digging in my soul as,
and it was so freaking painful.
Chandler brought it up.
I didn't even know it was a muscle.
I don't even know what the fuck that was.
Dude.
It's a motherfucker to get that work
done on David Goggins had it was an issue
with it as well.
It was keeping him from running.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean it messes up your whole core.
But this is simple plastic device.
You know,
you lay on it.
They send me a box of a man.
I see it,
I see it on my Instagram and all
the time it's the sponsored ad.
And I always like,
cause he's Chandler talking about it.
Yeah.
So I was curious.
Chandler's really into
his body and work it out.
He's got his own workout
program and stuff too.
So his Instagram page is good to follow.
It is.
He's a fucking freak and he
looks like a bodybuilding.
Yeah.
He's a freak athlete too.
I mean he's doing,
he's does these a medicine
ball backflips oh yeah.
Have you seen those?
Yes.
Yeah.
He's an athlete and flips
slam the medicine ball.
Backflips slammed the medicine ball.
Yes.
Jesus Christ.
He's a killer man.
He's another one.
That Bella tour fucking Stud.
Yep.
I mean,
he's one of the best 155
pounders on the planet.
No doubt about it.
100%.
I agree with that.
Just to going to change the name.
Yeah.
Scott Coker.
I love you,
but the name is wack.
Yeah.
Bella tour.
What?
Isabella?
I have no idea.
I have no idea,
but I'm,
I feel like you can kind of feel the
difference in their promotion when you go
and they're getting bigger and bigger.
Right.
But you can feel a difference
when you're there of course.
But you see the talent
that's in then you're like,
oh shit.
You know,
they got goldy over there now.
I miss gold,
gold.
These shout out to my man.
I saw him when I was there.
He's always,
always puts a smile on his energy.
I miss him.
I love Jon Anik too though.
And um,
you know,
I just think they just don't
have the funds that the UFC has.
Yeah.
It's just,
they don't have the deep pockets or the
UFC and the UFC has been around for so
long.
They just know how to do it.
They just made the right moves.
I mean,
look,
there were the ESPN man,
that's so crazy.
It's amazing.
I'm so awesome.
When that was signed,
I was so pumped just to see,
think what is going to be in five
years when they're famers with ESPN,
like how much we're going to be
on TV and the shows they're doing.
They're doing this thing to that.
It's like a,
not only are they going to fall to
winter around after their fight,
they're also gonna
follow the loser around.
Well,
to get into your life.
I mean,
yeah,
it's going to fucking suck.
Hey,
can you think about it?
It's like,
I don't want a camera follow me around.
I froze,
but they want to see how
it affects your life.
Like,
like me,
I've been,
I mean obviously I've been
pretty pissed off about it,
you know?
Right.
Like me,
if I wasn't staying busy with
my businesses and my family,
like I would lose my mind.
Like,
I would like to see that,
like say Brian or tig after
he fought Max Holloway,
he goes into that fight looking
on beatable and gets just,
just touched up,
you know,
Max Holloway just touched him up.
We really got to see who the fuck Max
Holloway is after that fight and his
distance control pace is output.
Everything.
He's just a champion.
He's just a fucking champion.
His mindset,
he's just a champion.
Gangsters,
gangsters.
They come in.
I love it.
He's so gangs or tag is as tough as they
come to him and he just wasn't ready
for that yet.
It was,
I think he will be man.
Like he's like,
you seem like that.
Like I have a camera
phone around after loss.
Like I think he's looking
for new things now too.
Like that's what I mean.
If you're a free guy that takes a loss
and you don't branch out to do new
things,
you're never going to get better.
Well,
his Jujitsu is off the charts.
When he grabbed a hold of co cubs neck.
When he got the Doris at the
end of the first round was like,
Holy Shit,
it's over.
But the,
the bell rang and he got out of it.
But then the around when he jumped
on him and grabbed that guillotine,
he went over the top of him.
Like whether it's standing up in a clinch
and got it and then came down on it
and then had it in the air.
It's nasty.
His technique is so fucking sharp
and he could do that with everything.
I mean armbars trying to get
like a good squeeze cardio too.
Oh yeah.
Well you know what,
he's,
he's real legacy Jujitsu.
He comes from,
you know that Henner and here
on camp and you know from,
that's Horian school
and were hoist was from,
that's the torrents crew.
I mean that's,
that's right from the fucking motherland.
But that is,
and you know,
there's a term that some people get
offended by that term is basic Jujitsu.
I'm not offended by
that at all because the,
some of the very best guys of all time,
whether it's hodge or Gracie or Hixon,
you don't see them doing like weird stuff.
It's all very standard.
It's not,
I mean,
there's basic striking.
Yeah.
Max Holloway beat or take it.
He was basic striking to beat him.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Basics win national titles and wrestling,
100% a high crotch,
100% you know,
a sprawling stand behind,
but it's the level of the basics,
and this is what I was gonna
say about Max Hallways Jujitsu.
It's like the level of his basics.
He's just,
it's so fucking polished.
It's like as a,
as a person who loves martial arts,
for me,
when I see someone who's
technique is that sharp,
I'm like,
whoa.
That's what I want to tell people.
This is why I get frustrated.
When I see people that are on their
back and they're in the open garden,
there are,
their legs are just kind of sitting
there flailing away and the guy's got his
arms on the ground.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
he's,
he's giving,
giving it to them bars.
He's giving you all my plots
as he's giving you a sweep.
He's setting himself up and
people don't know what to do.
That's one thing.
I've added a lot to my game lately.
He's been at Gracie bow a flip it and
Monica is my Jujitsu and I haven't got a
chance to show you.
I've been talking about it
and like the Cody fights,
but obviously those were
ended up on their feet.
This one I didn't get a chance to show it.
I was hoping we were going to go to
the ground like I want out wrestle,
pseudo,
you know,
I felt strong.
I felt good.
My,
I was working with Darryl Christian,
I'm at wrestling.
My,
my Jujitsu has been on point with Fleet
Bay and I've been adding a lot of crazy
stuff to it.
Um,
because like Dwayne's only
been out three days a week.
Right.
And we kill it while Dwayne's out here,
but then when he's gone,
I work on all my other stuff.
So it's forced me to get into my
Jujitsu little bit more as well.
And,
uh,
I've been doing so good,
man.
I be wanting to show it off,
but I haven't got that chance.
Does he,
have you ranked,
does he give you a bill?
I don't do any g he calls it dude,
look gay.
My friend calls me a blue
black cause I Q u a blue belt.
But really you black,
you know,
so he calls me a blue black.
She want to wear the
[inaudible] just to get a belt.
I do.
Um,
I always just out of camp
I always figured out like,
hey,
we're not at a time like to get in there.
I only time I feel like I can go and do
guid training is when I'm not in camp,
which I want to do it until
I get a fight lined up.
And actually it was just thinking that
I'm going to go and keep my weight down
and good way I can do in Yoga,
but why not go and do some gigs?
You did too.
Um,
just to do it for fun.
I'm in and show that I can do [inaudible].
Um,
it's fun.
It's,
it's,
it's a whole nother game.
Yeah.
But when I'm in camp training,
I need those fast cramps,
especially being at a
lighter weight class.
I need them wrestling scrambles.
And especially if the guy likes to Hutto
like we're not going to do Jujitsu,
we're going to do grapple
and we're going to do MMA,
Jujitsu,
you know,
of course.
Yeah.
And so I needed that
kind of like fast motion.
Um,
especially with smaller guys,
but especially sweating slippery and you
really need gable grips and over hooks
and yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's just the problem with D Jujitsu,
there's great things to,
at one you have to be very
tactical with your defense.
You can't just muscle out of things.
And that,
that's a big shock for a lot of people.
Like wrestlers in particular that
you used to just exploding out there,
not everything in reengaging.
And when you get,
you get your collar's grabbed.
Yup.
You're like,
oh shit.
So it's choking.
Someone has your sleeve and they
have your collar and you're like,
ah,
fuck.
You know,
I'm locked up here.
But it's funny.
It's like more realistic
for as a street fight.
Oh yeah.
You know,
like,
well that was going to say like,
the last thing you ever want to do is
get like in a street fight with like
someone who's a judo practitioner,
you know,
like you just get like,
um,
uh,
John Hackleman had a,
he had a thing on his Instagram
yesterday about that where it's like he's
pointed to the,
to the,
the floor of the cage.
It's like now imagine this is a fight.
This is concrete and this is you and
someone getting hoists in the air.
It's like take down defense,
which is so fucking true.
So,
so true.
I mean you,
if you got an a like Hector Lombard
or someone like that as a judo.
Yeah.
There it is.
Imagine this is you and this is concrete.
Fuck yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Especially if somebody's really fucking
throws their legs up in the air and
comes down with you.
Fighting in the street is so dangerous,
man.
Oh Jesus.
So dangerous.
Just hitting your head on the concrete.
Oh Man.
One getting knocked out and
hitting their head on the concrete.
It's just so dangerous.
Yeah.
And it happens every God damn day with
people who don't know how to fight,
which cause they watch the shit and
they think they can go and do it.
You know,
like I can fucking do that.
A couple of shots of Tequila and yeah,
the best youtube videos
ever is watching that stuff.
But it's always like,
Oh man,
that guy might be dead.
Well if he's not dead,
he's fucked up for a long time.
Yeah.
I don't think people understand.
I think I'll do more jets once I'm done
fighting like Jiujitsu just to try to
get ranked.
You know,
I'd like to be a black belt one day.
She works for sure.
Just so we can make it just,
just to have that,
uh,
would you like to compete?
I Dunno.
I Dunno what I'm done fighting.
I don't know if I want
to compete ever again.
Right.
I've competed my whole life.
I haven't competed since
I was eight years old.
I've never had a job.
Like I've had side jobs and stuff,
you know,
but I've never had like a real,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I thought I was going to until I dropped
out of school and decided to become a
MMA fighter.
I'm parents like you're crazy.
I don't know.
You're obviously crazy,
but the most crazy things that you had
this thing in your mind that you wanted
to out Russell.
So Hutto yeah,
I can't have,
it's different man.
Imma may resonate is different.
It really is,
man.
I mean he's,
trust me,
I would have been a
feat in it's own right.
He's a great wrestler,
but it's different man.
Um,
but the fact that you wanted to do it.
Yeah.
I
want the,
I want the toughest tough man.
Like I'm,
I live by the sword,
die by,
I got there.
I,
I sling leather.
I Bra,
I want to fight.
Like I don't have boring fights.
Um,
I want to,
that's why I wanted a challenge.
Max Holloway.
That's why I want to beat Henry Su.
Hutto I want to be the
best and to do that,
I feel like you really
need to challenge her name.
Um,
I'm not just talking the talk,
I'm not just doing it to,
to talk shit.
I really want to do it now.
Where does the 135 pound
belt sit right now?
Because you're the champion and if you
do decide to pursue the flyway title
again for everyone else and
that Bantam weight division,
this is kind of a cluster fuck.
Right.
I agree.
We got a big fight on Saturday with a,
since Alan Marlin Mariah's huge.
And they,
they've already thought before too.
So,
um,
we'll see what happens with that fight,
you know,
and Cody Garbrandt his
fight and Pedro Munoz,
that's coming up soon as well,
right?
Yeah.
That's coming up in March,
I believe.
Is that what that does
that the Vegas to 35?
Yeah.
So there's a bunch of big
fights in that division,
but I'd say the one that,
that,
that really kind of plays a factor
would be a cin seven Marlon Mariah's.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
which I have beaten to a since hell.
Right.
And one of them rise had been
looking good as well too,
but since I was going a big wind streak,
so I will see,
man.
I mean,
it depends if a fight,
so who do at 35 to like,
I don't know what's what.
I mean,
obviously I want it at 25 so he's talking
about saving the flyweight division.
Let's pump this thing up.
Let's get it done.
Like I want to,
but you don't want to relinquish
your 35 pounds crowns.
What if they come around and they say,
Hey,
you've got to defend.
I want to be active too.
That's also something I want to
say when I was getting on here,
cause I'm calling out 45
from calling out this,
but also don't want to be the guy that's
just going to walk away from my belt
either like I want to be the
cowboy Cerrone and be more active.
I haven't been active enough lately.
I've been too long.
It gaps a fighting big,
but because he's fights
have been built up,
hyped up,
people get hurt.
This and that.
I want to be a little more active.
I'm always in shape.
I'm always in the gym.
Um,
was be a little bit more of the
w one of my training partners.
Why don't Shalita he fights.
He fought for fights for
bold tour in 10 months.
You know,
like I want to be a little more active.
That's how I get paid.
I'm sure.
Turning 33 on February 7th so my
career's not going to last forever.
I want to start clicking and paychecks,
you know.
When do you think you're gonna do you
have a big game plan or when you're going
to ride off into the sunset?
Uh,
not necessarily.
I guess when the opportunities
that it doesn't seem,
it doesn't seem like it makes
sense as well as maybe my health,
as long as everything's going well,
um,
I feel healthy.
Um,
which the way I've been treating my
body is the healthiest I've ever been.
Um,
which is crazy.
so as long as I have the
right people around me,
like my wife and my
coaches have told me like,
look man,
you need to hang it up.
And I feel like I have
those people around me.
Like I don't want to be the,
I mean,
I don't want to talk shit.
I don't want to be like the chocolate
l fighting because I need it.
Right.
Another reason why I've
created other businesses too.
I don't have to fight.
I don't,
I don't want to fight cause I have to,
you know,
so I've been,
I've been really smart with my money.
I've been really smart with my
investments to where I could walk away,
you know?
But,
um,
I have too much to prove right now.
You know,
I have too much to get back at him.
First and foremost is
fighting in century pseudo.
Um,
well I'm,
I'm glad to hear that you
are like thinking about that,
that you're planning for the future.
There's a lot of guys that have done,
like Mike Bisping has planned very
well for the future and you know,
uh,
there's,
you know,
Brennan shops like the fucking gold
standard and he's really taken off since
he's decided to retire.
But it's,
you know,
there's a lot of stuff that you can do.
It's good to see that
you're doing this and,
uh,
tell people how to get
ahold of this flavor.
Republic Spice Company.
We're on a flavor republic.
Dot.
Cio,
we are on Amazon.
You go,
cool.
Yeah,
you can find us anywhere.
I mean obviously I love people to go to
a website to really check out who we are
and the story behind us.
Um,
I've started my fit to fight
program@tjdillashaw.com
and you have an APP as
well?
Uh,
my app it,
what's it Sam's at but
I've created with him,
it's called train champ.
Um,
it's a training lab.com.
so there's like a difference.
So if you are into martial
arts and getting in shape,
my fit to fight program is,
is going to not only make you better
technically and I feel like it's one of a
kind of teaches MMA for everything.
So like kickboxing from him,
a boxing from MMA,
wrestling from May and Jujitsu
for an instructional thing,
but it's also a training program and
strength conditioning for him in May.
Right.
Everything's based
around like a fight camp.
That's why it's fit to fight
Sam Calvert has is like the um,
if you're really into your body,
you want to be healthy,
want to get in crazy shape or if
you have goals to gain weight,
lose weight,
get your hair analysis done and
realize like what's in your body or
supplementation.
They do go hand in hand but depends like
say if you want to just be more of like
I'm getting in shape and be healthy.
That one's like you'll get
more information you can
ever imagine off for Sam's
App.
Like when I tell you about stuff,
it's hard for me to
even explain everything.
His App or his website will
tell you more about it.
And your stuff is all web based.
You're fit to five programs.
Yes.
So like Ipad,
laptop,
yes.
My fit to fight.
Like once you buy the fit to fight,
you get all 140 videos.
It's like all the cart.
You get them all like,
and I run you through like,
um,
so say we're doing kickboxing
today for our workout.
Like I've worn out a class,
we're going to do kickboxing drills and
then I'll pair them up with a string
conditioning workout that will
make you better at kickboxing.
You know,
maybe I'm doing some
core stuff or some uh,
footwork drills and then I'm
doing how to throw a head kick,
things like that.
It's um,
it's a full,
full schedule,
you know that little website
to Oh that looks nice.
Thank you man.
It took,
it's taken me a long time to build it.
Um,
been over a year of recording videos and
building it and obviously it's like 15
years of my knowledge of me putting in
through wrestling and in all my main
career and stuff too.
So I've been doing that.
I'm doing so much.
I have a,
a company I'm starting,
well not starting and franchising out a
cold press juice company in Yorba Linda
called clean juice.
It's really cool.
I'm opening that up here in
the next couple of months.
I am,
I'm really thinking about my future.
I've got a one year old kid and I got,
you know,
futures of having more kids.
And so I wanted to be able to be around
and have my career set up for that,
you know?
That's awesome,
dude.
Well,
listen,
best of luck
to you.
Congratulations on everything you've done
so far and can't wait to see you back
in there and let us know,
like when you're fighting again,
and we'll let everybody else,
my,
I'll let everyone know,
man.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you very much,
TJ.
Dillashaw ladies and gentlemen.
Hmm.